so we got some pretty sad
breaking news a police officer has died
of his injuries sustained during the
storming of the capital
and i don't i don't know uh why anyone
would want anything like this i mean
i don't know it's just it's just
miserable we spend all year complaining
about the violence from antifa and the
destruction and the vandals and the
burning
we talk about doesn't work i show all
the polls explaining how they lost all
their public support
following the storming of the capital
they're losing trump supporters are
losing public support
and now trump himself has just come out
issuing a statement
condemning the violence the criminals
saying that there will be a new
administration and a peaceful transition
so i don't i don't know what to uh what
to say to you know these trump
supporters that think what they did
somehow helped them or whatever but i
can tell you
you're left with two scenarios i suppose
with donald trump coming out and saying
that it was essentially wrong and he
denounces this and it was un-american
you either have a people defying
claiming to support trump but actually
defying what he asked for
when he said go home in peace and people
said no and stayed
and you know fought with cops or
whatever that's really weird that you
would support the president he would
tell you like hey this
is what you should do and people
wouldn't listen or you have uh
you know trump unwilling to do you know
all these people are claiming
you know the people who are claiming it
was good or whatever well trump said it
was bad so i guess
you support a guy who doesn't have the
guts or whatever
i think ultimately in the end trump
condemning this is the right thing
and it's very very simple no matter what
you think
this is what i say about antifa and the
black lives matter riots
it was satisfying to their emotions and
it did nothing for them in fact it
destroyed the support they had across
this country of course they still enjoy
corporate support of course all that
stuff
but from all of this they you know they
ended up losing support and now
trump is uh absolutely losing you know a
lot of the
uh a lot of support he had i'm not gonna
pretend like you know all these trump
supporters are also abandoning him or
anything like that
but you you see it more worryingly than
any of that though
is the the escalation that we're seeing
from democrats
media pundits screaming on tv and cnn
saw their highest ratings ever just
around 9 million
official numbers i believe is 8.2
million so you could just say eight but
we're saying around nine million
you think cnn's gonna stop now chris
cuomo and don lemon
going back and forth insulting people
berating them and mocking them and
talking about stupid trump supporters
are
how stupid these flyover states are this
sentiment
is generating them massive ratings and
so long as this hatred persists
the only thing i can see is escalation
and so we're gonna talk a lot about it
and uh it's gonna be really interesting
because we actually have two journalists
who are there on the ground
uh you guys want to just introduce
yourselves because you've both been here
before
i'm richie mcginnis uh yeah the chief
video director for the daily caller
richie mcginnis on twitter and
everywhere else
and uh you were actually in the building
i was in the building credentialed
i'm a credentialed we we are
credentialed the daily caller is
credentialed by
the house radio tv gallery so i did have
my credential although it was taken from
me uh
during the melee wow and yeah field
correspondent for
the daily caller jorge ventura you can
find me at ventura report and hori
ventura tv
and yeah i got uh got to arrive a little
bit after and uh just kind of document
the aftermath of it and uh
it's you know still crazy i think we're
all still trying to wrap our minds
around it so apparently you guys got
some crazy stories but
interestingly too jorge you did a bunch
of interviews with people about their
businesses being shut down in california
yes yes so we've been um so essentially
what happened was is
during november during thanksgiving week
i flew back home to california
and it was just literally just like a
family family vacation and as soon as i
i landed back in california i live in
the antelope valley
community in palmdale l.a county put a
ban
to outdoor dining so as soon as i i
landed back home
um you know you just you just drive
around my community you could just see
all the family businesses
small businesses just going out um it's
just
you know big just seeing like the the
real life depression of folks losing
their job
servers and and a lot of my friends that
i have their parents own these
restaurants and
now their their parents are thinking
about filing for bankruptcy and
basically losing their american dream
and um
i think what happens to reporters is
living in dc
you do get stuck in a bubble you know
and and i kind of did forget being in dc
and just covering the civil unrest of
how bad the pandemic is just hitting
regular working-class middle-class
americans well so that's what's
interesting i think it's cool to have
you both both you guys here because i
mean first of all you're both there on
the ground richie you were inside but
jorge you've actually talked to people
about what is this the seed of a lot of
this anger not all of it i don't say
most of it but there's a lot of people
who are really angry
and a lot of them are are desperate yeah
and it has a lot to do with it yeah and
i think right now we're seeing a moment
in american history where when you just
push americans to the corner this is how
they're going to react
and you we i i got to see it in l.a
county because
you know ellie county puts the ban on
outdoor dining and now when i went to go
interview restaurant owners
it was depressing at first because
they're like hey it's thanksgiving week
and i have to lay off all of my stuff
and at that time they already knew
they're like hey this this is this
band's gonna go longer than three weeks
so now i'm telling my folks
hey you're not gonna have a job during
christmas so you already
have to see that but then you get the
other half where owners are saying you
know what
if you're going to put this ban on
that's it i'm just going to defy and i'm
going to stand up and all this
all of a sudden we're seeing this uh
happen in america then a lot of folks
that i interviewed too
they're saying hey this is not like a
left or right issue it's just anger this
is just us
wanting to earn a basic living and we
just feel like government is now really
infringing
and like i said we're just seeing i feel
like a moment in history where americans
are put in this corner
and i mean i'm not surprised about how
how they're reacting right now right on
of course we got luke rutkowski hanging
out welcome back beautiful and amazing
human beings this is the kudaski of we
are change.org a lot of crazy
information to get into that
i'm just going to just throw it at you
because like we seriously there's so
much information happening right now
it's absolutely like i'm like going
crazy here i already
it's they're not documents
but uh their notes about just everything
that's going on right now that is
absolutely berserk it's crazy a lot of
stuff
needs to be broken down and uh yeah
first thing we gotta talk about for sure
is is richie being in the uh yeah
but uh in the capital but uh don't
forget sacrifice she's pressing all the
buttons
and uh let's uh well let me just jump to
the first story
and then we'll we'll get into what what
happened on the ground trying to
understand how this happened this is
from
k ron four u.s capitol police officer
dies
after violent protests bring debt
bringing death toll to five
they say a u.s capitol police officer
has died from injuries sustained during
violent riots at the capitol on
wednesday
a source tells k-rons iv alexandra liman
that the police officer was hit in the
head with a fire extinguisher by a
rioter
and was taken off life support the
police officer is now the fifth person
to die as a result of the violent
protests
the other four who have died are
identified as rose roseanne boyland
now my understanding is she was she fell
in they believed she was trampled
kevin griesen and benjamin phillips i'm
not entirely sure
which one but one of them suffered a
heart attack one of them suffered a
stroke
and ashley babbitt of course she was the
woman who had climbed up in the window
and peeked through and the officer
shot her killing her now look
you know apparently some you know a
couple people had heart attack and
and one guy had a heart attack one got a
stroke they're trying to lump that in to
make that seem like that's part of the
actual riotous
death count and i think that might be a
little disingenuous although i guess if
you know if you have suffer a medical
emergency because you're older and
you're in the heat of the moment your
blood flow and all that stuff you're
going crazy and your heart's pounding
i guess it makes sense but it wasn't
like those people died because of
external forces it was just you know
their bodies giving out
as for uh you know ashley babbitt she
got killed and what was she really doing
but just climbing up and looking through
a window i mean come on
it's not like it's like i'm gonna sit
here and say that these people should
have been the building of course not
but i'm just i tell you man i have seen
these circumstances a bunch of people
run into the building
you see people who don't know what's
going on who walk up and they're just
bumbling around confused i've talked
about it over and over again
that what happens is someone runs up to
a door and hits the glass runs away
someone else runs up and sees the glass
falling and knocks out some pieces runs
away
it's all these little grains of sand
that eventually the doors open and
mindless people are just like walking up
and seeing the door open and walking and
going like wow what's going on
and then you end up with this woman now
she's got social media videos you know
ashley
she was very adamant she was very angry
at science trump supporter
but this this shouldn't have happened i
mean even if you know people were
storming the capital it's it's it's
it's it's absurd in my opinion now i got
to be honest i get it
you storm the capital you got itchy
trigger fingers from capital security
and it's their job to barricade the
doors and protect the people inside and
it's just
completely tragic now i'll tell you i'm
also mad
about this cop losing his life because
this is a look
i say this about the left all the time
they think the cops know what they're
talking about you see a cop and they're
like he's he should know
what i know and so they scream traitor
whose side are you on and that cop
doesn't necessarily know what you know
now i think it's fair to say a lot of
trump supporters a lot of conservatives
probably assume the cops
know a bit because they're cops and they
deal with this stuff all year
but i'm i'm not gonna pretend that you
know when you see cops going around
and destroying small businesses
throughout the lockdown just like
blocking doors
yeah that that we see in new york and
stuff violates the first amendment when
they when they when they're secretly
filming
you know jewish schools that is creepy
and it also violates the right to
worship and assemble
when they're shutting down churches
these were cops who are providing
basic security to our government who are
standing around saying
we want to make sure everybody inside
can do their job somebody bash this guy
over with a fire extinguisher
why why why kill the guy why would you
do that
oh man it's just it's infuriating yeah
um
you know many news organizations and
even some individuals are talking about
thoughts and prayers for the traumatized
congress members
people forget that people died here this
is a very serious incident
specifically talking about that woman
you know there's a lot of videos we
still don't know the full details we
hope there's an investigation but but it
doesn't look
justified and right now we're getting
the information that the chief of the
u.s capitol police is saying that the
police officer
involved in that fatal shooting has been
placed
on administrative leave and their police
powers have been suspended
pending another thing that really needs
to be pointed out scared cop with a gun
man
um yes but then also he was behind the
door there's a lot of different elements
that we could break down here
but another important one is that there
was police officers with
like full long rifles tactically behind
her yeah that was insane the police
officer could have killed other police
officers
and and and there was no threat to
anyone's
life and again i don't want to be
jumping to conclusions because
i do hope there's an investigation we do
need to wait for cooler heads to prevail
before making any kind of assumptions
and judgments here
but but just looking at that video
footage we should really prioritize
the truth about that event rather than
you know
in in my opinion you can't even compare
the two the the nonsense the the
hysteria
the the just hyperbolic bull crap on
mainstream media right now
oh i mean cnn's ratings are through the
roof so of course they're going after
trump hard
yeah you know but but look we got more
news here pertaining to the police
u.s capitol police chief to resign after
wednesday's riots
i mean so there you go that's the news
it's uh steven sund is resigning amid
criticism
over an apparent lack of preparedness to
deal with wednesday's violent mob on
capitol hill
you know i was i was on twitter and i
got to tweet something like
why weren't the police ready for this
and then i stopped and thought about
what i had just said when i made a
segment on youtube and said
i don't think trump supporters will do
anything i think they're going to go
they're going to support trump they're
going to rally
they're going to wave american flags and
they're going to march around i didn't
think they're going to be people who
actually
you know storm the barricades now
there's a couple of videos one of them
shows
the cops retreating as the the group
pushes through but there's a bunch of
different areas there's also an overhead
view
of all of the barricades in a massive
crowd shaking the barricades knocking
them down then rushing the stairs up to
the building
so i mean look that might have been my
video because i was up in that um
were you filming down i was up in the
media tower so let's let's
set up for inauguration let's uh uh let
let's do this let me get your thoughts
on uh on on you know this officer and
these people lost their life and then
we'll go into your story about
everything that went down so
you know just like i don't know tell me
what you think about what the violence
and all that stuff so
i mean first off i arrived basically
when they had already
amassed around the capitol and the
police had set up their line so right
when i arrived
uh the first thing i noticed was not
only were the police using
mace and bear spray but they also were
the protesters were using it as well on
the police and the police
were less adequately equipped than i was
as a reporter i had a
tactical helmet and a gas mask and
because i had seen the reports and i
rushed down there
and um you turned the michael yeah sorry
and uh so
when i got there i was extremely
surprised to see how unprepared the
police were usually in these kind of
situations you know where things are
escalating
you see riot police pour out but the
people who had formed the lines they
were all just
basically you know your standard uh
capitol police uh maybe they had
a shield over their face if they were
lucky but no gas masks but these these
people who were in the front
and you know spraying the cops and stuff
who were they were they trump supporters
because we're hearing a lot of people
are trying to claim especially
conservatives that it was actually
anti-fog but i've
i've seen one video where there's a guy
who does not look like a trump supporter
but he's got a trump sticker on his
helmet
bashing a window just like antifa does
and people are screaming stop him
and then a trump supporter grabs him and
puts him in a neck hole and pulls him
down
yeah that's also extremely
under-reported yeah what you just
brought up is an important facet that
there were elements from videos that
i've seen with people saying
stop this yeah i'm curious curious from
you guys because there's two kind of
theories out there
one is that there was inadequate
security and the police officers let
them in
another one was that they were just not
ready and they were overtaken
there's these two theories what do you
guys think from your personal opinions
what actually happened
yesterday it's kind of a a mix with both
they were for sure
not prepared under manned um i kind of
went in to the
kind of went into it the same sentiment
of tim actually even reported on the
ground was
i didn't think anything crazy was i
actually was anticipating more
black lives matter actors maybe making
their way down and then you know just
because that's what we've seen
in the past but from what i what i saw
is they were for sure
unprepared but to me i didn't see
anything that like jumped out and said
um you know these were nt for like i
just
you know i know that's not popular to
say right no that's you see that video
where they're yelling no antifa
no stop him stop but then again like
when there were these claims over the
summer that you know
uh right-wingers were infiltrating
antifa and blm
protests what were they you know did
umbrella man wear a maga hat when he did
the crime yeah
so antifa's not gonna dress up as antifa
um if they're you know trying to well
these you know what i mean yeah but
so so some of these so it's impossible
to tell really just because they have a
red hat on doesn't really well no these
guys didn't they had like a brown helmet
and then just like black block gear with
a trump sticker on it and i'm like
oh i saw the dude geared up and then
slide a sticker on his head to make it
seem like he's a trump supporter no no
this is interesting because
we've seen the media during the summer
trying to obfuscate some of the kind of
left-wing protests as
undercover right-wingers there was
government officials mainstream media
polit you know politicians saying no
these aren't you know left-wing antifa
these are right-wingers trying to incite
us to make us look bad
now we're seeing a kind of similar kind
of attempt here do you think it's
legitimate or
because other people are also adding
that there wasn't any kind of counter
protest when there usually
is that's what people are saying i don't
want to jump to conclusions i just want
to kind of hear your opinions on this
i think from just from my perspective is
emotions are
super high right now even from a
reported perspective
like even right after election if you
just told the truth about the election
people are are unfollowing you and
canceling you if you don't tell them
what they want to hear
if you don't say trump's going to be in
office after january 20
you're done so i i was already seeing
that and then this
i think is just adds on top of it like i
said um
i don't know what what's going on but it
just seems like no one wants to take
responsibility it seems like antifa is
just the easy skate go like
just anything hey auntie fan tv look
even before everything broke down
when i was doing interviews i was i was
asking folks do you think this
is kind of a civil war that we're headed
because what look whether you agree with
the save
uh to stop the rally uh march in dc that
moment is historic because we've never
seen anything like that
after a presidential election so we're
already walking
on you know uncharted waters so with
with this situation to me
um like i said i was asking folks do you
think we're headed to a civil war i was
nineteen out of ten they're saying this
is a civil war to us this
is a revolution not to mention like all
the crowbars yeah like people were
telling me
that implies premeditation what is a
crowbar used for like what for holding
up a sign
no absolutely not for breaking the doors
open correct
people had crowbars oh i saw probably
five or six crowbars a lot of them
actually
were just left by the doors where the
glass had been shattered what yeah
i got cause i got knocked down by one of
the doors and i actually was looking for
my phone and i found a crowbar
that's so weird man i don't know
i mean i just think everyone's emotional
right now you know and i think i
i don't know is this is this breaking in
you know i guess maybe in the 1700s
taking the state building may have
granted you some kind of power
i don't know how that works i guess
you're like i'm in the building it's
mine now
uh especially not today you know they
can issue a statement from wherever they
want
any one of these politicians going in
the building didn't do anything
you know i mean we've got videos of i
tweeted this out
uh the women's march took over the
senate building and then they shut the
whole building down
and they weren't worried about the fact
that there was like a thousand plus
people screaming at the top of their
lungs inside
was that that in heart was the heart
senate office building yeah yeah that
big like
um the atrium yeah exactly that's hard
yeah so i understand it's a fairly
different circumstance that you know
storming through the barricades and
fighting with cops and pepper spraying
them and smashing windows and breaking
it is very different plus it was during
the electoral
you know vote count so you know i just i
wonder what the goal is for either group
like did the women's march didn't
accomplish anything what did they
accomplish really yesterday then some
people have lost their lives
i mean to me just yeah you don't
accomplish anything and it just seems
like trump
just lost a whole bunch of support we've
seen now the senators kind of
rescind their objections in and out this
also gives
big tech the biggest excuse in the world
as we've already seen to just censor
trump i mean it just seems like
after the election trump is going to
disappear on social media i don't know
oh he's already basically he's
definitely banned
from facebook now according to mark
zuckerberg's own personal post
the new york times yesterday had two
articles talking about the importance of
limiting speech and we are seeing people
left right and center just being taken
down for the minuscule
post and even memes there's a meme of
that that guy who's wearing the the kind
of weird headgear and the face paint and
it says
you know 2021 uh i thought it wasn't
going to be crazy
and facebook is banning people's account
for that post
and it's not even a political post it's
not even taking side it's a joke it's a
meme it's people saying this year's
pretty crazy
banned by facebook and they just
released these vague terms
saying if you are supportive of this in
any way you you get cut
michelle obama just released a statement
talking about how you know
it's dangerous to have social media but
there's a big argument i want to make
here and i really want to kind of talk
about the dangers of censorship
especially when it comes to cubanon
because when we look at qnon this was a
movement that was essentially censored
but the conversation didn't end it was
festered and moved into the
dark corners of the internet where it
grew that conversation could have been
addressed could have been handled in a
way where people could actually talk
about it in a rational real way instead
of just
going on this bizarreness there could be
people pushing back
yes one of the problems with parlor for
instance and i'm not here to rag on
parlor in terms of what it is
i'm just saying one of the problems
philosophically is that when you when
all the trump supporters leave twitter
because they ban trump they go to parlor
where they no longer hear the arguments
from the other side and the same is true
for the left the problem is
for the longest time twitter has just
been banning arguments from the right so
the left only hears their own refuse
back at themselves
and trump supporters leave and then
start doing their own refuse back at
themselves not just twitter facebook and
youtube also going after who
people who are debunking the q anon
stuff people who are saying hey
let's take a legitimate look let's look
at the evidence let's look at the
accusations let's actually look at this
and they were debunking q anon stuff
independent creators had their channels
taken down because they were doing that
youtube youtube yes youtube did that
took down
bunkers yeah i had to go through all my
old videos being like okay i can't even
talk about this and i and i removed some
of them because youtube was on a huge
purge
against you and on and whether you were
against it or for it and that is
something that really pushed the
conversation
that made people on the fringe even more
fringe
even more extreme and they and they were
coming back and saying well if we're not
legitimate why is youtube
blocking us we must be against the
system we're not going to get to stop
say this over target exactly we're over
the target because we're getting the
flack we're getting censored
and and this is why i'm against
censoring speech and this is why
this is an extremely dangerous time
because a lot of people are using this
situation
to push for extreme censorship and the
destruction
of civil liberties they they've censored
the president of the united states
i mean look you can you can complain i i
think his
uh the tweets he put out where he said
this is what happens when a you know
great and glorious landslide is taken
you know but then he did say go home in
peace never forget this day
it was far from a perfect statement
trump could have done way better and so
i think i i i can be
somewhat critical it was kind of a tepid
statement the left is of course freaking
out about it it wasn't an overt act of
support or anything like that but
it was pretty close to it but regardless
of what you think about that
they removed him they took down the
president
that's crazy to me and they're probably
going to take down the rest of his
social media
and they're probably going to make sure
that he never has a voice in this
kind of larger political discourse like
he previously had before and this is a
president
where it's going to be set where the
tech ruling elites
mark zuckerberg is going to decide what
you can and cannot hear michael tracy
had a very
interesting point about this that i
think is is worth talking about
he said quote philosopher king mark
zuckerberg
should definitely get to unilaterally
decide
based on his subjective political
judgment
which definitely is not dictated by the
fleeing passions of the day
whether the public is allowed to hear
from the elected
president good system and he makes a
good point there
uh but but i wanted to kind of bring him
back to you guys here because one of the
talking points is that this was an
insurrection
these were terrorists they planned the
coup d'etat we have
john bolton the man who knows almost
everything about a coup d'etat because
he
orchestrated them in the third world
coming out and saying this was
definitely a coup d'etat
from your experience was this a
professional coup d'etat attempt even
well i mean what i saw going into the
capital
were some people who were intent on
breaking things but mostly a lot of just
kind of bewildered
people who were kind of bumbling about
and and kind of taking in the novelty of
it
and when i arrived in the rotunda you
know there were probably about 80 people
in there
and a lot of them were just milling
around and taking selfies and
and it didn't seem like they were you
know trying to run around and smash
anything
um i i think really what what happens in
these kind of situations
is is once the chaos starts you know
once a couple of people break through
that line once a couple of people start
pushing up on the cops
then it doesn't take much for other
people to follow suit
so so let's just start from the
beginning and let's hear you guys a
story what happened
well we'll start off with well actually
you can start off in the morning because
you were there
so i got there around um eight in the
morning and as soon as i arrived
at the washington monument it was just
like a sea of people you know flag
how many do you think i mean from my
perspective i think
minimum how over half a million people i
would
say in the hundreds of thousands i was
there for obama's first inauguration
and second and trumps and it was not
quite
the same numbers as any of those but it
was close half a million
yeah it was a lot let's not forget is it
half a million i i mean i think i mean
it was
because we for sure two hundred for sure
because the women's march they said it
was around there
and i looked at the photos um you know
the aerials and stuff i mean it was
hundreds of thousands let's let's say
that
it's definitely more than tens of
thousands i think so what happens what
happens it's also so so so my
understanding is that
trump got on stage and said you know
everybody standed attention
and said your orders are as such go and
destroy and then start passing out
torches
right yeah like trump trump directed all
of them right like i said i got through
a kidding by
yeah yeah i know but when i even even
getting there like i said i got in
got it there eight in the morning it was
a sea of people it went all the way back
to like the washington monument um
when trump trump i think took the stage
around noon and he spoke
for about 45 minutes now where i was at
you couldn't even like
hear him so like the people were just
there to like kind of be there
but even during his speech people
already started going to the capitol
building
so um like from where i was at you
couldn't hear anything but like i said
it seemed like a normal day
you know i was i was watching trump's
speech
and it was before anybody could have
even left the ellipse people were
already able to get to the capital so
like trump and the people who are there
so i i knew people who were down there
and i was asking them i was like are you
anywhere near the capitol they're like
no i'm at the rally trump's giving a
speech
i'm like but there are people at the
capitol building right now who were like
you know so anyway continue continuing
but basically yeah i was more in the
back section but even even during
trump's speech like i said you
already see people flowing in and
heading to towards the capitol building
so i did my interviews and then i
thought it was gonna be a regular day so
for me i was like you know what this is
my chance to like
go get some mcdonald's and like just
kind of like recharge be back at like
five for the action so
when i when i went to go do that um
that's when i got the news of
basically the the breach happened and i
think that's literally right as i was
going i think
richie then so i saw i actually had a
friend who worked um
at the capitol and they were up on the
up on the roof and they said they saw
cops running around
and i was like that's weird um i should
probably get down there
so i went down there and i bought i
brought all my gear because i
i didn't suspect that things were going
to get bad but i wanted to be ready if
they did
and the moment i arrived i mean there
was you can see the clips my first clips
on
my thread on twitter it was basically
art they were already clashing and i
went up in that
um tower that scaffolding and you can
see that view
as the lines are broken basically it's
the same thing you know two or three
guys make it through
they get clubbed they get knocked down
brutality
everyone gets even more mad and then a
couple more breakthrough and then
the police are overwhelmed and if you
see the numbers i mean
it's not a matter i think that the
instances that have been cited online of
cops you know
letting up or whatever i don't even
think it was a matter of that because
even where i was where the cops were
giving it their 1000 i mean you can see
on the video
these cops were trying their best to
hold on to these barriers to hold the
line
but they were getting pepper sprayed
themselves and i saw a number of them
injured and going back and getting
medical attention
so um i think they would have been
overwhelmed no matter what given the
chaos that was unfolding so how did how
did you so what happens you're standing
up on the scaffold you see the line
break
what happens next so i see the line
break and as the line is breaking i have
to give a shout out as my mom's birthday
and i called her in the morning i'm not
that bad a son but she called me as the
line was breaking
and like on an iphone if you ignore the
call it ends the video
so then if you look on twitter my video
is broken up into three parts because
my mom called me a second time and i
declined again and i
she forgave me for ignoring her call on
her birthday so thank you mom
i appreciate that but um after that by
that point
the police were concentrating themselves
kind of in that open area on the stairs
but people are already climbing up the
scaffoldings and
into an area where they could still
access the the capital
cops so actually the scaffoldings made
it more difficult for the cops to defend
that area surrounding because basically
that
there were you know like little nooks
and crannies where people could climb in
climb into those scaffoldings climb up
and get up on the bleachers
so then so what happens like when did
people get in
take us through how you ended up in
there from up there i could see
basically the flow of people going up
the stairs a lot of them just stopped
and decided to
wave a trump flag or you know wave
whatever flag they had
i caught video of one guy who got a fire
extinguisher for somewhere and was
spraying it down on the cops below him
well yeah
um so when did they go inside so that it
was right around that time
that the lines broke and it took me
about 10 minutes before i realized like
there's a
there are a ton of people going in there
and i have congressional press
credentials so
i was like i'm going in i'm going to see
what's going on there that's how you
were up there in the first place mm-hmm
yeah um well no so i actually just i i
had come down so quickly that
yeah i wasn't up there in the first
place but um
by the time i got in there i saw a bunch
of people in the rotunda but then to my
left i saw some protesters kind of
rushing down
the hall through statuary hall towards
the house floor
so i went through statuary hall and
there was already like
um evidence of some riot control
munitions being used
um you can see like the pepper on the
ground you know and and also
the orange tinge of uh pepper spray yeah
you know like it has a
red color depending on which brand it is
but um
so i proceeded down that hallway and i
actually saw a group of protesters
surrounding the house doors and there
were like eight or nine of them you can
see it on my video right as i arrive
and actually some of them are shouting
like you killed her you killed someone
you killed someone
and so they were already somehow aware i
think that was just immediately after
the shooting had taken place
and one of them had wedged himself right
in that door and i think that's the
photo that you see with the police with
their guns drawn
right that guy with his face right there
because the there were only two or three
police at the time they're actually
outnumbered right in front of the doors
and they were trying to pry him off but
because they were outnumbered they were
basically waiting waiting for
reinforcements
and it took about five to ten minutes of
kind of like a little
standoff before six or seven more cops
showed up and
and then removed them and we were pushed
back out into um
through statuary hall and into there
there's a clip where you're saying you
can't breathe and there's a cop saying
he can't breathe
what happened with that okay so that was
after we were pushed through statuary
hall we were back into
the um capital rotunda which is the big
underneath the big dome
that's like the biggest room there and
there were still you know maybe 100
people in there
the cops started to push us out but
there's there's kind of like a maybe
only a 20 foot wide
uh doorway there and so what happened
was all the protesters got bottlenecked
there
they were pushing back and then there
were maybe 40 or 50 cops at the time
pushing
against us so i was you know as a
reporter it's it's valuable to be
in the middle of of the protesters and
the cops so you can kind of show both
sides
so i was stuck in between and i
literally had you can hear on the video
one the cop had his billy club on my
stomach and i was like can you just take
it off my tummy
like please like my tummy up here well i
don't know why i said that
i don't know why i said that but i think
it was easier for me to see
tummy than like stomach yeah i don't
know why
um but you could hear another you never
know how you act in a crisis
people people think they know how to
respond you don't sometimes you blurt
out tummy
but it felt a lot better once you got it
up on my vest why was he doing it
he was like holding you back or what so
he was pushing against me to try to push
the protesters back but
there were probably 30 protesters behind
me pushing against me
so i literally was just i mean i was
telling the officers like there's
nothing
i can do and he was being pushed behind
by his own officers so
this is why you shouldn't go in between
yeah i understand what you mean but you
know you're trying to you're trying to
stand not necessarily
in between but like off but still sort
of like so you can see both groups and
what they're doing
because if you're behind the protesters
you won't see what they're doing exactly
and if you're behind the cops you don't
see what the cops are you got you got to
get that angle that's
it's tough and then you end up getting
there's like 20 minutes stuck in there
as
just pushing back and forth wow but then
they broke through or what
um they eventually pushed the protesters
all out oh okay they cleared it out
yeah and and then there was another
scuffle by the the door to the exit
which had also been smashed and they
were trying to close but the protesters
were blocking that
and so that was like kind of the last
final push and i got
tossed into the door breaking news uh
this is pretty
big news by an ap reporter named mike
balsalmo who says quote u.s capitol
police say reports that an officer has
died
are not true although some officers were
injured and hospitalized yesterday no
uscp
officers have passed away this is again
according to mike
valsalmo who is an ap reporter uh that
just
broke this story a couple of minutes ago
and i didn't want to interrupt you no no
no no no here's the challenge for us
here as with anything putting in the
news
i've got what 800 plus sources saying an
officer died of being hit and have the
fire extinguisher and we have one guy
saying it's not true so who do you trust
i actually know mike he does great work
right he does i will
i trust him i do do i do too i do too he
he did i can't remember what he he
covered some big events he did uh what
mike did was
was really cool during the portland
riots he got inside
access oh yeah federal officers so he
actually got to be in the line with him
and
he got to actually interview and tell
their story so yeah i think uh
i'll trust mike on that one uh but at
the same time we'll you know we'll we'll
see
we'll have to wait for things to kind of
i mean look it's it's really fascinating
that
i mean we've got you know kron4 we got
cnn we got a bunch of sources saying
this officer died now he's coming out
saying the capital police are denying
that
it makes sense yeah sometimes you know
what happens is that cnn will get a
story and then everyone copy cnn and
cite them
and then someone goes for a comment goes
whoa you gotta stop well tim
actually speaking of the the ap oh mike
um well i got there a little bit after
i guess um the crowd has already been
cleared out at the u.s capitol so it was
between
4 35 and as soon as i got there there
were still hundreds of folks at the u.s
capitol
and there was a lot of rage going on in
and so i got on the ground
and uh the ap was actually they're still
reporting they had a couple cameras i
believe they had about four cameras
tripods the whole thing
and the whole crowd just starts turning
on them attacking them
smashing their cameras yeah and then
they took down the barricades then in my
video you could see one man with the
american flagpole just
you know trying to hit them and then
smack the cameras down and then
eventually the crowd just
destroys um the whole equipment and so i
took that footage
and then i i uploaded on twitter then
the
the response online is um you know folks
we're just like cheering it on
and it's my mentality that's why we use
our cell phones and look and i get it
you know there's a lot of anger with
with the with the mainstream media but
i think for me as a takeaway with as a
reporter was you know
and maybe richard you have some thoughts
on this it's like during the summer when
we filmed
press getting attacked from black lives
matter activists and we put that online
that same crowd would say
hey these are the anti-fascists they're
against you know the first amendment
they're against freedom of press
yep but when it's their side it was
acceptable i think
that's a really interesting point and it
goes back to what you were talking about
with the small businesses earlier which
is
you know over the summer what we saw
were a lot of really
people who felt like they'd been sold
down the river and they were angry
about it and uh that anger
was aimed towards a system that was
enforced by police and so the
argument of blm and antifa is always you
know they in fort enforce a corrupt
system therefore all cops are bastards
so we saw that turn happen um
not this last rally but the one before
where all the proud boys were basically
saying
you guys are enforcing this system
that's stealing our election
therefore you guys are terrible but i i
we started seeing the sentiment against
police when the cops were enforcing the
coveted lockdowns
and some of them were perceived as
arbitrary by locals notably in staten
island
where you had this one bar that decided
to open up and define to the lockdown
but two blocks away
there's a restaurant with full like just
operating like normal and so the locals
get angry
and they say what's this all about why
are we locked on and they're not they
say well you're on the border of the of
the red zone
so when the police come come out and
block the door
people in staten island trump supporters
come out with trump flags
surprisingly thin blue line flags
yelling at the cops
and then it escalated when we actually
saw the conservatives take the thin blue
line flag throw it on the ground
stomp on it and then throw it in the
street and then i think
you know you got conservatives saying
it's the birth of right-wing antifa well
it's important to point out in stan
island the zone that was restricted the
most was a republican area
uh that many people said that the local
democratic government was selectively
choosing to enforce these rules
they were also targeting the jewish
areas which is really weird
yeah the hasidic jewish community and uh
we talked about that extensively on this
show and even had uh
heshi on the show who's still out there
and uh going to many rallies
i actually made my way up there and
uncovered a story with the
uh with the hasidic jew community where
they just defied the lockdown orders and
kind of partied out
out and burned some masks yeah one of
the crazy things too i guess is just
people there's a lot of commentary on
the the wrong target i guess they're
saying why are you going to the capitol
building you know they're
they're doing this uh i guess you call
pro forma or ceremonial
uh electoral you know account and it
didn't matter if it was i don't know or
not
it doesn't matter if you're in the
capital where's the actual organization
and the tar and the protests of these
actual corrupt institutions
i get it they view the capital and
congress as as corrupt in a lot of ways
but what about the media and what about
more importantly
organizing and planning so that what you
do is effective in some capacity
because now what we see here is already
there's joe biden coming out numerous
occasions now saying it was insurrection
domestic terrorism and things like that
so i you know we had the patriot act now
they're going to come out with the like
securing american freedoms
and and now we're seeing an argument to
remove trump from office uh with the uh
uh article uh 25 yeah there my question
is is
i think if that had been a blm march
then
perhaps the they would have had more
guards who was who's in charge of that
who i i honestly think whose job is it
to make sure that that capital doesn't
get attacked
it's capital police right there's park
police involved
muriel bowser and the federal government
who of those people [ __ ] up
well it's the sorry messed up fudge
it's the capital police who uh who's now
resigned i suppose
but i think the issue is to look i think
it was it was
they screwed up but more importantly
nobody thought trump supporters were
gonna do this
come on i had my helmet and my gas mask
on yeah but
i guess we've seen the escalation now
like i mentioned with with cops and
and you know the proud boys fighting but
to to like
when you look at anti-fun they're
showing up and they've been burning you
know antifungal blackouts
have been burning things down for years
they're like we better secure this
you get the ellipse full of a bunch of
middle-aged and older trump supporters
waving little flags
and trump giving a speech and they were
like man he's gonna be fine you know we
don't have anything to worry about
apparently they did the proud boys uh
the previous rally they weren't just
waving little flags they were
running through the streets shouting f
antifa
and looking for fights and they got the
fights but
to assume that the regular trump
supporters would bolster that you know
what i mean would
would escalate i agree with that but i
don't think it takes very many
in the group in order to to create that
kind of situation and i think
you know what some people have said is i
i can't believe i'm seeing people
that think it was a good strategy i
don't think it matters whether
i don't think that matters i you know
you know what man when we see corey bush
and aoc
they're calling for the expulsion of
members of congress who supported trump
she directly said that like ted cruz and
holly should be expelled
from congress it's like okay like you're
a congresswoman they're senators that's
a very you know it's a bit different the
upper chamber
but that's an insane and dangerous
escalation
and it's going to keep happening nobody
wants to back down cnn doesn't cnn is
looking at their their cpms
or you know on youtube perhaps but
they're looking at their ad rates
and they're jeff zucker's cracking the
champagne and saying we gotta keep this
going somewhere
and let's not forget there was a uh just
a month ago there was like reports of
jeff sucker wanting to step down because
of the trump administration so
you know for him it was like hey i
already wrote what i could do you know
we already hit the highest ratings we
can you know this
under the biden administration you know
it's going to be you know lame duck
media
um so yeah there was already reports of
jeff suckers trying to step down but
with this it's gonna you might want to
stay in business
so someone today took chris como's
comments a few months ago where he said
protests are not supposed to be peaceful
they took the full segment
and instead of doing the b-roll of black
lives matter during the summer they
replaced it with what happened
in the capital and everyone's freaking
out about that video i mean obviously
it's doctored obviously it's fake
but we have to understand you know a lot
of the bigger kind of mainstream media
institutions have kind of led
this kind of foundation this this
groundwork that it's okay to use
violence for political means
as long as it's your political meaning
exactly i mean vox literally had an
article that said riots are destructive
dangerous and scary but can lead to um
serious political reforms
this is what people are you know people
i got an email from someone saying tim
you're wrong about violence and they're
like look at all these things throughout
history where violence has brought
change and i'm like bro that was 400
years ago
like there was no mass media there's no
mass communication and so yes
one day somebody was leaving their farm
and went to town hall and saw a
different flag there and went what
happened and they were like oh he's in
charge now they're like oh
but we have to understand blm had the
support of the establishment of the
mainstream media
of attorney generals that literally let
off a lot of people
trump supporters don't have any of that
so that's why this was a
big miscalculation this was a big
misstep and i think this was just uh
a fervent crowd just getting raised
here's the question though is that
do you think the conservative media's
reaction has been similar to what
uh quote unquote liberal media's
reaction was to the blm riots it's
always like
well i don't know specifically but but i
will say
conservatives especially like ben
shapiro will immediately
come out and condemn on principle things
yeah like if the violence is wrong if
the left does it at the right time
doesn't do that though there's right
wingers detesting everything that
happened yesterday
fox news as it was happening had the the
head guy of cpac on
talking about how it was justifiable to
assassinate and kill an
unarmed woman who he thought at the time
was a teenager was that match lap
yeah match slap was literally so so fox
news already was saying this is
disgusting this is horrible this is bad
the people deserve to die when they were
shot unarmed by the cops that's that's
the messaging that was coming out on fox
a lot different
than of course msnbc saying oh this
protest is mainly peaceful
everything is there's a there's a police
station on fire behind the guy
yeah now now i know there's a fire but
it's mostly peaceful
and now these same people are lecturing
us about how everyone who was there
whether innocent or not whether bad or
not whether doing something illegal or
not
deserves to be sent to jail for the
maximum amount of time
we deserve to lose our civil liberties
we do we deserve to lose our speech
because this happened and this is bad
and this is horrible because violence
should be detested at all costs
meanwhile they were cheering it on just
a few weeks ago here's what i love
though
when black lives matter shows up in dc
they paint the street black lives matter
then they get a ridiculous amount of
police to guard the 20s
no no i'm talking about guarding the
capitol buildings yeah you can see the
the picture of cbp doing their trainings
and they're like we're dispatching cbp
and the left i think it's it they make a
really great point when they say
why were so many cops deployed when we
come out and then when it's trump
supporters they don't bring out that
many that that much at all and i'm like
that's a really great point
because they didn't secure this trump
supporters break in
and because they didn't secure this
everyone now must suffer yeah social
media must be censored
you know uh people are being banned from
twitter like crazy
it's there's tons of reports now of like
thousands of people just
getting their accounts just just axed
there you go
some a group of several hundred people
breach the barricades they go in the
building and like you said it seemed
like a lot of them may have been just
bumbling about
bewildered there were guys smoking
literally rolled and smoked
doobies in underneath the capitol
rotunda wow
and there were like uh three or four of
them that i filmed
and they were just happy to talk to me
what kind of weed they were smoking
and that's crazy i don't know masks
they they know these can't smoke a
doobie with a mascot no but i mean like
these people didn't realize i'm not
talking about like
covet masks i'm talking about oh yeah
the amount of cameras they have in there
i mean you walk into that rotunda and
you you're
you're getting a facial scan these
people were bumbling
and noting just i don't know fools
yeah i was watching that guy baked
alaska just live streaming
in there i was like oh prison oh yeah
prison i also don't think that they
underst like i think a lot of the people
didn't
yo that painting over there is literally
priceless it was painted in like
1784. you know and it's this massive
like oil painting and there's just
literally guys smoking doobies in front
of it
and i got pepper sprayed in that room
and there was tear gas deployed in there
there was there was like uh pictures of
like i didn't see it personally because
i came in after but
like i said i saw the evidence of riot
control munitions so
yeah how do you clean the the the this
brand the fire extinguishers
people don't realize that all throughout
the hallways
of these buildings are priceless old
portraits and paintings
that are well taken care of i remember
when i went to the white house
there there were rooms where like i went
to i went to the bathroom and there was
like this ancient sword or whatever i
shouldn't
hand but like several hundred year old
swords like outside the door and i'm
like what is that like oh that sword is
from this battle where you know this
this
you know ambassador came here and i'm
like that's the bathroom
that's the white house when you're in
the capitol building too it's like
that's
real artifacts and art of history
people going in there and smashing
things and letting off the fire
extinguishers and stuff
and then of course the right munitions
that's that's that's
you know what you know what man you want
to know what story really breaks my
heart
the burning of the library of alexandria
yes yeah
you guys you guys know that right like
the old old library asian history
that like man all the all the things we
could have learned and all that
history's gone
so i when i when i when i think about
what you're talking about these
paintings mm-hmm
i don't like it but i i will say at
least
in the situation that i was in the
police
showed a lot of restraint in only
pushing you know and basically relying
on taking selfies with people well so
like i said i didn't see any of that
so i can only speak on what i saw but
those police
in that room i saw maybe one or two
times pepper spray deployed
in a very like they were they were
outnumbered and it wasn't until you know
the attack police
arrived uh there were like a dozen guys
intact they were outnumbered i don't
know if you guys seen that video
uh bg on the scene got it where you had
the u.s capitol police guy he was like
in the corner literally
like just shivering quivering yeah and i
was like whoa that was like
oh man i feel is it isn't that weird
though were you
were you guys quivering when this all
this is going down were you you were
inside were you shaking with fear and
like scared like as people were coming
in
you you've got the risk richie of of the
protesters
and the police you're not a participant
you're there as a journalist they were
smashing cameras outside so the cops are
going to be like i don't care they're
going to go after everybody
then you got the protesters who are like
what someone's etched to murder the
media
oh yeah i saw that how was it were you
quivering richie were you terrified and
shaking
i think the only reason why i you know
would think that i would get targeted is
because i think i you know
i'm not going to dress up like a trump
supporter right but when i go to an
antifa riot i'm dressing up like antifa
to blend in so i think maybe you know
i stood out more than i would i just
normal what i just mean is
you you you are in this a credentialed
press
you normal access to the building and
all that stuff you're covering what's
going on
and there's this cop who's quivering and
terrified now we have this photo of all
the members of congress are like hiding
and ducking terrified
to i think to be fair they don't know
necessarily what the threat is all they
know is they're told
something's going on and they found pipe
bombs so you know that i understand
but it's it's to me the cop to see that
video of that cop
shivering and i'm like that dude look
man i you know i once interviewed this
nypd detective
and he was he was talking about the
problems of the the cops and guns and
unarmed people being shot and he said
it's because you got scared people with
guns you got to have
like there's nothing more dangerous than
a scared person with a gun and i'm like
oh there's a lot of things more
dangerous you know like a
grizzly bear running through new york
but i get your point i get your point
and so when when i see a video of that
i'm like
dude is not prepared for this not at all
yeah there's there's memes going
around showing the pictures of the
legislators and they're kind of hiding
and uh the caption reads uh these are
the people that send us to war
send your children to send your children
to war and again people react
differently during moments of panic and
chaos and you don't really know what's
going to happen until you really face it
until you have that adrenaline rushing
through your blood until your
your your instincts take uh you know
just take over you know rational
thinking is out the door
some people are able to quiet their mind
and see things very slowly but
very few people can do that yeah let me
let me ask you guys this too because
this is something
uh there's an experience that people
often say when you're in this conflict
situations it feels like time slows down
is that is that was that resonate with
you guys it certainly does with me when
i used to be on the ground with this
stuff
yeah there would be gunshots going off
and it's not
it's like of course it doesn't slow down
like not literally but there's like
you're just heightened your
your brain's going a million miles an
hour and it feels kind of like you're
taking off
like neo in the matrix and the bullets
are coming and they're so slightly
moving away
like me being in these different rides
in different countries and in places
like ferguson
it's not that time slows down so i
explain to people but it's like all of a
sudden
my like you know when you're when you're
looking at something you're focused
right
like there's a beer bottle over there i
can read the beer bottle and i can see
in my peripheral vision some you know
some stuff
but like in these conflicts it's like
all of my field of vision becomes
focused in focus and i can just see
everything's coming in and it kind of
makes it feel like time is flowing your
senses are honed in and you're in the
moment
and every sound every every little thing
you pick up on and you register and it's
there i think um i read it in a book
it's um think and grow rich by napoleon
hill and i think
maybe for us because we're a journalist
and i think this is what it is for us i
think we
when we're in those moments i think what
it's called it's called flow state for
us yes
yeah for us i think since our our
focus is so high because we know i think
the moment the intensity the
significance and also i think a lot of
stuff we cover is historic so i think we
know
to perform our best that we just kind of
click into this flow state
and things just tick and sometimes you
can't just describe like for me yeah
like i'm uh you know people always come
up to me and like oh man
like i love what you do you're such a
brave person and stuff i'm like i'm not
like
i don't you can't get me to go on a
roller coaster like i won't do a roller
coaster i don't want to do really
well in those moments when we're in
those chaotic scenes and
you know what's gonna happen i think as
journalists we kind of maybe click into
this flow state because for me yeah
the the i don't have any fear i just
feel more focused i feel
i actually more feel more alive than
ever like i feel like
i don't know i feel like everything's
just yeah i feel like everything is in
tune but i mean
what do you think richie about that i
don't know how i think it clicks in for
you definitely that but
i think there's a unique feeling that
i've felt uh just a handful of times
over this
you know riotous period and um it's a
feeling of how
is this my country and how is this
happening here and
another time is when they try to pull
down the jackson statue right in front
of the white house and they spray
painted black house autonomous or bhaz
right um on the saint john's church and
that was another moment and they set it
on fire yes and then the video of the
fire from that church is no joke
no joke we're lucky they put it out and
it's also hard because you know
in most of these instances i'm covered
in pepper spray so it's like
it's like this moment where i take off
my gas mask and i'm like yes this is
i'm i'm seeing what i'm seeing is real
you know what you wanna you know what
man
i've been in i don't know i don't i i've
got this
sinking feeling all day since yesterday
since all this stuff started going down
i can feel it you know right in the pit
of my stomach just this low-grade
worry i don't necessarily want to say
fear because not like i'm heightened i'm
like alert to like something coming but
it's like a worry-like you know
kind of stress right now i don't know if
everybody's feeling that way
the people who are watching because i go
i go out you know i'm going to go to the
gas station or whatever i got to eat and
people are just going about their lives
like nothing's going on
and i wonder if it's because i've seen
this in other countries
the stuff that we're seeing with the pop
with aoc and corey bush saying expel
cruz and holly
aoc said we must pass cory bush's
resolution expelling and investigating
these republicans
i've seen that kind of stuff before i've
seen that language before
and i've seen where these street
protests end up with people
you know going through the doors of a
building and taking it over and shutting
things down
and now it's happening here and there's
no escape
because i always knew when i was in some
of these countries watching the cast and
the destruction
and yeah criticize it it's the
journalistic it's the parachute
journalism privilege
of knowing when all is said and done i'm
on a plane
i'm back home i'm kicking back having a
burrito and watching spongebob or
whatever
like family guy i don't got anything to
worry about this is your country right
so i'm not trying to be disrespectful
but you know when i've been to places
like venezuela and egypt ukraine etc
and i'm watching these things happen i'm
like i know
that i'm dipping my toe in and at a
certain point they're gonna call me back
and i'm gonna go home
and then i'm gonna go to my friends but
wow how crazy was that cool you guys
want to order pizza
now i'm sitting here at my house
watching videos of my own capital
and seeing similar things and people
these people who are pushing these
narratives these people on cnn who are
are just i watch this thing with cuomo
and don lemon doing his hand-off
and i almost threw up on my mouth a
little bit i'm like they love it
they love it they're they're they're
egging each other on you know uh
it's like don lemons laughing and like
eating chips i don't know what he was
doing
and they're just like these people are
terrorists and then joe biden comes out
and says it's domestic terrorism and i'm
like
74 million people voted for donald trump
74 million people
and they say in a poll 45 of republican
voters supported
the storming of the capital this is not
a joke you cannot be calling for
escalation
ted cruz was right when he said we need
to put the anger
away we need to come together we need to
figure this out and what was aoc's
response
you should be expelled and i'm like i
have seen this
and i know where it goes and i'm
watching it happen i'm it's freaking me
out
74 million people disenfranchised
ignored censored and shamed
and it's not and it's not going to get
any better i mean i mean we talked about
this for a while we knew this was
happening
and that feeling that you're getting
it's here too uh it's it's like a
heaviness it's
it feels more like the bottom of my
stomach
because it feels like this is just the
beginning and it's only going to get
worse from here
that's why you know also i i was there
in venezuela i went to certain places
like
zimbabwe to somalia to see just chaos
and
when you're there you know you do have a
moment where you're like
okay i'm away from it i finally got away
from it but when it's in your backyard
when it's happening in the united states
when you're seeing
people hurt injured when you're seeing
people just
lost and and you know them it's
something that
is really a feeling that that's very
hard to describe but that pit
it's there i had it since yesterday as
well and i
i sadly feel like it won't be healed it
won't be fixed
anytime soon especially if we have these
institutions continuing to put fuel on
the fire when i was in uh
egypt and and i know i tell the story
about egypt a lot but uh
it was uh i think it was like the fourth
of july actually in 2013 maybe
when they started going in and arresting
journalists
there was reports that the the military
had gone into various news outlets shut
them down arrested people and i'm like
i gotta call my security people i gotta
call my support figure out what's going
on
and immediately when i heard the
journalists were getting arrested
it felt like someone grabbed my like my
stomach and just squeezed it as hard as
they could because it's like that stress
immediately like oh man
i'm in this country the revolution is
right there
so i was like i got to get my wits
together i had everything packed and i
would
you got to stay calm you can't panic you
know because i didn't know what was
going on
right for all i knew they were shutting
down the journalists reporting on
everything it turns out they were
targeting certain journalists that
supported the muslim brotherhood
i went down to the lobby asked some
journalists and they said
don't worry everything's cool i was like
what's going on are they going after
journalists it's something we got to
worry about and these guys were just
like no no they're going after
pro-muslim brotherhood networks and
stuff and i'm like still kind of messed
up they're doing this
but we should be good right they're like
yes and then when the apc's rolled in
i called up the crew and i was like i
think it's time to go to the airport
we leave to go to the airport and i'm
like i'm getting that relieved feeling
and then they announced the bridges get
shut down like we would have been stuck
inside there
the crazy thing i'll tell you man when i
was in venezuela
i was uh we get back to the hotel we we
weren't there for like
you know the protests were going on and
we're going around
uh talking to people it's we're in
caracas and it's one of the it's the
murder capital of the world
and uh we get back we go to the hotel i
go take a shower i come back to twitter
and i have like ten
thousand mentions my twitter's blowing
up at this point when i was working i
had like 30 000 followers so i'm like
how do i have 10 000 mentions and it was
a ton of threats
insults some death threats and so
that's what it happens again right that
feeling and so my immediate reaction is
what do we do and they said don't leave
right now it's dark out it's dangerous
wait for the crack of dawn get in the
car get to the hot get to the airport
and get out what happened was this
this pundit on tv had gotten some tweets
from some american leftists who were
saying i was working for the cia
wow and so he ran with it and he called
me a mercenary from the media who was in
ukraine and all this stuff
and so my main point is you know i get
that feeling and i say
okay be calm what's our plan we're
getting in the car we're going to the
airport and we're getting out
we get i get in the plane and i remember
taking off and as soon as the wheels
left the ground
the feeling lifts and i'm like i'm
officially in the air
i hope they don't turn the plane around
and some crazy stuff happened afterwards
but advice there was an intern who was
venezuelan and he runs up to me
immediately says
how did you get out of the country and i
was like i got on a plane and he was
like you're lucky bro
if you had stayed a little bit longer
you probably would have been flagged and
blocked because they arrest people for
way less than what they accused you of
long story short there's no getting on a
plane and leaving right now
this stuff's all going down and you know
all day today i'm looking at twitter and
i'm looking at the media and i'm seeing
pundits leftists democrats and they're
saying
we need more authority we need more
powers we need retribution we need
reconciliation
you saw that tweet from david cross
where he said
f that i want blood did you see that
maybe he was
trying to make me be funny because joe
biden called for unity it doesn't matter
if he's trying to be funny or not
because we've seen too much violence a
an antifa guy shot and killed a dude in
portland a trump supporter
and so people are are they're not even
on edge anymore they
we're off we're falling right and then
you see something like that
was that twitter removed was he banned i
don't know i don't think so
but it's not a joke it's not at all
there's no there's no plane to get on to
get out of here
we're in it and then even after the uh
the election results cnn came out and
made like an hour special where
they compared the whole trump movement
to nazi germany so it's just like what
yeah it's it's it's like having these
things play out in mass media
i think is fueling keeps fueling the
division and we are
so far apart from each other and then
you know for me growing up in california
it's just like if now i understand you
know people in california don't even
understand like the problems of like
someone in middle america and like
michigan and in ohio you know for
someone in california
they think you know if you vote for
trump you're this crazy
you know racist person and then you know
you could go to somewhere like detroit
and say hey
what's the reason why you voted for
trump and they'll tell you well i had a
great job in the automobile industry but
then the nafta deal came
now my job ship now i can't feed my
family now my kids are on opioids now i
have a divorce
my kids are on are on drugs you know no
one speaks to me in washington so it's
just like i don't
you know how do we get back where we
could just have regular americans back
at the table talking about
about the about these issues but uh i
think media right now is just playing
a huge role in the division division and
it's just it's no se and it's from both
sides not just from one side from both
sides i mean
that was what happened after kenosha
which is like
one side of the media basically was
telling a different story than the other
yeah and me being the witness caught in
the middle like it's it's
was incredibly infuriating to see
you know one side not want to hear what
you had to say what you saw
not like your opinion on the thing what
you saw because
they had some political opinion on it i
remember when that was happening and i
remember saying there's no going back
from this
once you have mainline media
institutions excusing violence
for political means there's no way you
could put that
big i can't curse here uh big genie back
into the lamp
you can't um the genie's out and
uh it's being vigorously rubbed by all
the special interests that are
benefiting off of this larger divide and
conquer agenda and these people fighting
each other and sadly
i mean when you're when you i think one
of the issues that led to this
is the censorship more censorship is
going to create more problems more
disenfranchised people more people not
being able to talk
out ideas but they're going to go to the
extreme because they can't
resolve it with proper communication
that's one of the most important things
that i think we should also talk about
and also the copycat effect which i
want to talk about in just a little bit
but you have a point this is no we got
some
big news actually this news is from
yesterday uh
heidi hatch from kutvs confirmed a utah
man involved in the protests
uh this uh of all the persons in utah
this spring was in dc and stormed the
capital amid violent protests
is a man named john sullivan and he was
arrested as a member of black lives
matter during during the riots in spring
and apparently he claims he was there
just to document
but he was there as the woman was shot
so it looks like we do have confirmation
of leftists
part of the protest that stormed the
capitol building
i brought this up you know as a lot of
people are saying like matt gates said
there's a facial recognition company
that found antifa or something i don't
think that's true i think they denied
that
i don't know where he got the
information from but a lot of people are
saying this was antifa who did this
well there's not a whole lot of evidence
but we we do have a guy now we have him
that's what i was wondering we asked we
were asking some questions the other day
antifa always counter protests they
always show up they announced they were
going to show up where were they this
time
and so i said this a few days before now
that
the proud boys and trump supporters are
mad at cops what happens when antifa
says okay
and then they don't okay my enemy of my
enemy is my friend i guess
is that is it possible that some of
these people at least well
we got this from heidi hatch of kutv i
believe she's of kutv
yes kutv news confirming this guy
he's listed as an organizer of of the
provo protest arrested accused of
rioting and making threats
and they even say in the uh kutv story
or the woman she says
he does not align with donald trump uh
uh politically so we have leftists that
were inside the capital
at least we can say that much i don't
know what that means moving forward but
and that's that's what i think why i
always just say the term protesters
i mean i know people always get mad oh
it's a riot or it's this or it's that
i mean i just think that's a generic
term as opposed to saying
antifa blm rioters you don't know just
because they're wearing all black
you know they could have come out there
with good intentions they're just a mom
who you know
wanted to you know her kid got beat up
by the police you know
so you don't know just because they're
wearing black or just because they're
wearing a red hat
oh okay yeah you support all the
president's policies that's why i don't
care for the tribalism
that when that dude and all black showed
up to that was an auto zone or whatever
in minneapolis started smashing things
out immediately said that immediately
they said
this guy is far right like the left knew
or a cop or or a cop right
now we have the exact same thing when
this goes down
they're saying it was antifa who did
this and it's like there may be we've
got this we got this guy right
so this was from yesterday they're
saying they confirmed it but come on man
there were people wearing trump hats
we'll get we'll get a lot more
information as we see who does get
arrested
right because they do have fake facial
recognition in there right inside the
capital
i don't know about well we have a whole
track trace and database society with
the nsa and fbi pretty much knowing
everything about everyone through their
cell phone
they could easily geo-locate everyone
they don't need to put out these
uh you know these notifications like the
fbi
in the usa today they released saying if
you have any information
notify us send us all your photos send
us all your tips send us all the
information
we're going to go after everyone that
was inside of there
and again we also another important
element to kind of really think about
here
from my experience covering events mob
mentality is also something that people
really need to consider because yes yep
there are some bad
bad actors but there's also some people
just caught up in the crowd
there's one famous photo i just sent it
to you lydia of this like older
lady with her juice box literally just
kind of like
not knowing where she is and
uh yeah she was in again like walked
down the steps by capitol police
yeah mike cernovich had an interesting
kind of uh
comment about this uh let me try to find
it here because
um what was he talking about he said
let's just say
this is after donald trump's
announcement he said let's just say that
the trump campaign will not be creating
a bail fund for his supporters
lots of innocent people going to get
caught up i feel deep sadness for them
some bad guys sure but droves always
find
themselves in the nest this is this is a
really
comment a common tactic we see among
left-wing organizers
first thing i'll say is i'm not saying
this as an attack outright on the left
i'm just pointing out the right is not
organized they're not
there's no like there's there's very
little organization on the right they
don't go out
it was not organized this whole thing
was poorly organized no bail support no
masks no plans no strategy
but among the left what they do is they
know who their marks are
it's like body filler essentially they
need a certain number of bodies as cover
and they want regular people to get
arrested so what we've seen in the past
is
you'll get like 10 extremist activists
or extremists and they'll set up
an event that's palatable to a thousand
regular people who want to wave little
flags
and say you know save the environment
once they get that march going
they use that as cover to go and
do some kind of action that results in a
mass arrest
that way when these hundred or a
thousand regular people are confused
and getting arrested you get a bunch of
press they want that to happen
imagine if ten people stormed the
capital just ten people would be like oh
10 people went in i guess whatever
were they arrested yeah i guess you know
it would have been really easy for the
cops to handle it
so they know they need bodies
unsuspecting
doting you know individuals who have no
idea what's going on
who see an open door and walk in
confused bewildered
and then the people who are pushing for
this who want it to happen can get away
with it
and it's and i'm not saying that it was
on purpose here i'm just saying
what you end up seeing is often
unsuspecting and
psychological phenomenon of like a mob
mentality
yeah if a couple people do it that's all
it takes
across the country you can even see from
the footage too because
right when folks are in there they're
just like like richie said they were
taking selfies smoking pot so
even for them they were more shocked
that they were even in there they were
just kind of taking it in they didn't
know
whether there was you know staging a
sit-in or you know
or occupying the capitol building for
several hours you know they didn't even
know they were
you know i was watching that you know a
bunch of streamers just
having fun smoking pot it was kind of a
it was kind of like
that's what i'm saying this if if that's
antifa then i mean
yeah i mean wow yeah i don't think any
ntf is going to dress as undercover
trump supporters he didn't want to go to
jail for 10 years to smoke a joint
inside a capital but
under a lot of that trump put in place
yeah the idea that antifa would take
their mask off put on a maga
take their mask off put on a maga hat
and then walk in and be like i'm
actually a trump supporter here's my
face
like they wouldn't do that yeah but
they're but they're worse there were a
lot of people wearing masks
i saw some of these people and i thought
to myself trump sports don't go around
wearing masks like that
i've been to so many different trump
rallies you've got trouble makers that
are not left-wing but there's also
boogaloo boy types they wear masks
you know so we don't necessarily know
who these people were again we do know
one of these guys
was a blm activist from utah who was
there at the capitol
not surprised we've seen those videos of
black lives matter and boogaloo boys
shaking hands you see that one yeah
the antifa guy is like you stood here
with us today so we're we thank you
and then the boogaloo boy says something
like hey man like we agree the
government's bad and they're like all
right
well they agree you know so they like to
claim that boogaloo boys are somehow
the same as trump's reporters is just
not true it's not true
trump supporters are very much like
liberals you know and not not
politically of course
but in the sense that they like the
country to a certain degree
you know like they're okay with how this
country functions they're okay with
it's basically like reform versus
revolution you've got
extremists on both sides who want
dramatic change overhauling revolution
and then you've got the regular left and
right wing individuals
and the problem is the left in this
country has moved so far
left but also gains has so much control
now of institutions
that regular trump supporters who
probably would be satisfied with winning
an election
are now feeling just totally cut out
period and so
you then start seeing you know i think
they're going to take advantage of that
that anger they have now will be used by
more extremist types including antifa
who's
clearly those who do they're from blm
well and we saw what happened in the
first
the very first rally uh basically there
were
tons of footage of people in red hats
walking through blm plaza
similar situation didn't realize what
they were walking themselves into with
all
like a mass of blm folks in the plaza
getting their butts beat and then the
next time around the proud boys say not
this time
and they all travel from around the
country by literally the thousands and
show up
ready to roll and that time i mean i
think there was a lot more of the
aggression coming from the proud boys
we've got we've got some huge news
betsy devos has resigned oh right
writing in a letter to the president
there is a quote there is no mistaking
the impact your rhetoric had on the
situation
and it is the inflection point for me oh
she was a staunch reporter too
staunch supporter and not only that but
she was
you know a lot of uh you know we have
jack murphy on the show and he talks
about democrat to deplorable he wrote
this book
he interviewed a lot of people and one
of the big issues was title ix right
reform from these colleges
making sure due process was standing and
and these critical critical race
theories being challenged
and she was very much doing that that's
what you know trump brought her in for
before some of the one of the reasons at
least now she's out
i tell you man what happened at that
capitol you know you know what man look
there are a lot of people that don't
listen to me
the life doesn't want to listen to me
for sure and many of them staunches
trump supporters don't want to hear
it but when lynn woods snapped off i
said this is bad when sydney powell
snapped off this is bad
tucker carlson said i called cindy said
where's the evidence and she didn't give
us any and what happened his ratings got
cut
in half if you listened to tucker
trump would be in a better position
right now when i said
lynn wood is tweeting like crazy and is
one of the most destructive things for
the president
i had a bunch of just like ardent trump
supporting people say you're wrong he
knows what he's talking about like no
dude whether that's true or not doesn't
matter
okay fine i think it i think he's he's
he's off
i think he's gone nuts i don't know
what's going on with him but he's
delegitimizing
the president and so when all this goes
down you need to understand the impact
that going into that capital
had it scared people nobody wants to be
it's just what do you accomplish exactly
i don't i don't see
what goal would you would have where
that's like a good way to get there
people thought that i guess
you know uh there's that video of that
woman and she's crying and she's like i
went and they amazed me
and they're like why did you go in and
she goes we're starting the capital it's
a revolution like what do you mean a
revolution
you a bunch of random people walking
into the capitol building
is a revolution like um that's not you
know it's not what's kind of the saddest
thing too that we
should just take away is you know ashley
the the
air force veteran who died i mean she
served our country she served in wars
only
to die in the u.s capitol building
i mean it's just a disgrace the people
in this country
are getting really mad and you know i'm
hearing people say
that it's a reminder to you know the
republican party or whatever that
you know we're we're here and we're
allowed or whatever and i'm like
the republican party just like does what
the democrats want them to do for the
most part
they they feign objection they feign you
know oh we're gonna fight back and then
they obstruct and then nothing really
happens
like lindsey graham coming out and
saying like oh that's it for me i'm like
oh come on
like as if you were really ever doing
anything for anybody come on you
these politicians win because people go
and vote for r
or d not a person you know so what i've
been warning for some time is
you got a lot of angry people in this
country for a lot of reasons before
trump it was the loss of manufacturing
jobs and the collapse of these small
towns and the opioid crisis
and trump was addressing that in many
many different ways whether he solved
those problems another question
now with the covid lockdown a lot of
this is being revived and people are
angry
and they're especially mad now that the
president they supported after 74
million votes
loses but they're particularly mad that
there's a bunch of
signed sworn affidavits of impropriety
and it should be adjudicated and and
there's weird uh
mathematical anomalies and questions
that want to be raised
all of these things need to be presented
now here here's the thing
they talk about on the in the media oh
it went to court
these things were in court and they were
all you know shot down by the judges
well
not on the merits right on procedure
here's the problem
you actually had advocates in the senate
they called them the dirty dozen because
the media was insulting them the
republicans who said we are going to go
through the evidence it was your chance
to have the evidence presented
in the joint session exactly and what
happened they broke the doors in
they evacuated and that was it that's
what makes zero sense
it makes no sense they were supposed to
have their time
for the whole country to be watching the
tv goes on we're all watching this
cnn was on and they were counting the
votes and they were playing what the
republicans had to say
and i was like this is it the chance for
the american people to hear the argument
and then they evacuated shut it down and
that was it and then nobody was watching
and i was really interested on what josh
hawley was going to come out and say
because i was actually
shocked that he came out and was like
i'm going to eject something okay this
is one of the more rising stars of the
the republican party you know
he's come out and just set himself as a
populist he's
um he also kind of set himself apart by
like working with bernie sanders on
on the 2k stimulus check but once he
came out i said okay this is going to
get interesting
then you know ted cruz followed then but
like you said everyone is now jumping
ship
uh uh you know laughter ended up
rescinding her
her objection as well and it's going all
downhill real
real fast for this week what's the
reconciliation though
is there just none i mean oh well i mean
you got like ted cruz saying let's put
the anger aside and come together
but they don't want it cnn clearly
doesn't want it aoc doesn't want it
the jankyuger doesn't want it they don't
want it they do not
want peace and so the problem is they
don't realize
or they do i don't know when they point
to like this q anon viking guy
this is not the majority of americans
let alone
trump's base or the republican party
it's just there are fringe people
uh you know i really don't like it when
the conservatives say that antifa is the
democratic party and i'm like come on i
don't agree with it
exactly but they do think it's easier to
overthrow a feeble old man than a
fascist that's what they've been saying
on social media
but they don't like joe biden and so
i've even been saying like now antifa
and the trump supporters are
against the establishment right but when
you get
the the high-profile leftists claiming
that every person who voted for trump is
like a q a person and that's what they
do
you're creating very serious problems
and so they're like we don't want to
unify with these cute crazy people and
it's like okay what about like
the middle aged suburban housewife who
isn't all that political
and just vote a republican for the sake
of republican you're going to accuse her
of being a cultist
are you going to blanket everybody in
the same group well apparently that's
why they don't want to unify they don't
want to be
we can't associate with them they have a
a hyper-polarized view of the other
and that's all we get in media all day
every day is the other is bad the other
is bad
and i think the one thing that's unique
there as well
just in terms of the way that one side
is viewed from the other
i i don't think that i think that the
right might often say
in media you know the left is acting in
bad faith but they'll never
really like say you're ignorant or
you're stupid or you're somehow sub
smart enough to stand on the same plane
as me but having worked at nbc
and then worked at the daily caller and
for mark levin
i mean that's a very real thing and i
think it's really really really really
hard
until you're on that side and you
experience it we've got some uh
partially breaking news from the past
hour shamari stone
of nbc says breaking them outside the
u.s capitol a police officer just walked
by with a flashlight shined
in our parked suv in other parked cars
many officers holding assault rifles
run down constitution avenue an officer
just told me you might want to clear the
area
now i'm going to issue a correction for
shimari i don't believe they
they use assault rifles do they or
actually they're police they might
actually have selected selective fire on
these things right
yeah they're like fully auto usually so
they assault rifles absolutely okay so
it depends on the cop but but he's going
to attack police that are yeah
with full auto so these are actual
assault rifles okay so that's my my bad
he says again a u.s capital peace police
officer just told me sir this is an
emergency situation clear the area
police hold assault rifles and search
cars well it i want to just mention too
tim before me
and richie got over here one of our
reporters with the daily caller was
actually shooting some bureau at the
capitol and he let us know
uh after 40 minutes that he was on the
ground that he he was cleared away from
the capitol because they were searching
for i believe a second bomb right rich
there's
oh just right now right now tonight this
is earlier today this is that
yeah a few hours ago maybe three p.m
yeah wow so that was
yeah we we i forgot to mention that as
soon as soon as we got in the show but
yeah that happened earlier today we had
a daily call reporter on the ground
there
well i don't know what's going on now
something's happening i can't really
find anything but can you just keep an
eye on it yeah this is becoming the
breaking news show tim
yeah right it happens it happens that's
good
it's important to cover these events now
another thing i wanted
to add on your comments about the fringe
tim is that
the fringe is only going to grow because
of censorship
more censorship more people will go on
the fringe
and the mainstream media now saying we
need to ban them more we need to censor
them more is going to have the opposite
effect people need to realize that
and and another thing to kind of really
really kind of consider here
is uh the copycat effect because we were
just talking about mob and mentality i
think this is also something important
to consider
especially how the media many times
helps kind of spur on mayhem especially
with their coverage
of mass shooting events and this has
been criticized many times
through many scientific studies showing
how highlighting and glorifying a
shooter during a big
national event only creates copycat
shooters the mainstream media knows
about this the scientists know about
this anyone paying attention
knows about this but yeah if we want to
reduce harm
you're not going to create more fringe
people you're going to going to actually
address real issues like the copycat
effect that no one really wants to even
have a legitimate conversation about
that legitimate cause that legitimately
causes pain and suffering you know
what's really funny is uh andrew yang
had some tweets
where he said that media polarization is
causing this problem
he he talks about the issues that have
led to the hyperpolarization and then he
says partisan media and then he puts in
parentheses fox and a lot of people were
like why did you need to do that
you should not have done that he's right
i think fox plays into it
i think steven plays into it i think
msnbc plays into it there's just
you know 10 10 news outlets for every
one fox
exactly but regardless when you get that
it creates a problem
i've even self-reflected on my own
content where i'm often critical of the
democrats and i'll say it right now
i can sit here and say oh the tribalism
is all bad and i'm heavily criticizing
aoc
how do you get past i don't think it's
possible if ted cruz says we need peace
i say thank you ted cruz when aoc says
no peace
expulsion i say okay that's a problem
that's exactly my point which is that
if you wanted to have somebody on this
show uh
who was you know left of center it would
be much harder than
i presume and and that is exactly what
i'm talking about which is
he's beneath me because he thinks this
you know because whatever he's not
establishment legacy whatever
it doesn't work for the new york times
it's just absolutism it's authoritarian
pushing the humanism and the algorithm
also specifically on twitter promotes it
whenever you dunk on somebody or insult
someone the algorithm
is done in a way where more people see
that particular post
more people engage in that particular
post and you're seeing more followers
more likes more hearts
especially the more divisive you are and
we have to also i mean legitimately
point the finger at big tech social
media companies
that have been benefiting off of this
tribalism warfare
that they've been breeding they are
partially responsible for it and there's
a lot of people talking about all these
conspiracies but this is something
legitimately
that we should worry about that we
should consider on on a big level
because
these are the ingredients that created
this situation
these ingredients are only being added
they're not being subtracted this big
pile of crap family-friendly show here
but this
big stinking peanut filled piece of crap
is there because of specific
ingredients that are in there that could
be addressed but they're not even simple
conversations about them are censored
online and again we're never going to
deal with it if we don't have free
speech
it's easier for mark zuckerberg to ban
trump and then say
oh it's for your own good when in
reality he's just saying i'm more scared
to the left than the right
so one of the biggest you look at the
things that led to
trump's victory you look at the things
now that are leading to the anger
and one of which has been censorship for
some time people not being allowed to
have a voice
when you take away people's even ability
to argue with you
well then they snap and they get angry
and so that was a driving factor and
and facebook and twitter and youtube and
twitch and snapchat
all these different platforms are like
let's spray down
that you know the the we got we got this
big old pile of crap as luke said
they opened up a sewer line like let's
don't worry we're solving it we're
cleaning it up and you're like dude
you're just
filling it up with your phone is filling
it up man yeah it's not gonna work i
think
this is a recipe for disaster because if
you're gonna censor trump and his
supporters in the next four years we're
just gonna get
a trump or trump if you don't make sense
we're going to get someone
even if if they left uh trump was crazy
we're going to get something
even way more more radical my my biggest
thing i actually wanted to ask you guys
now that we're all here is
do you think that the media just pays
attention and gives
too much story to these fringe actors
and the reason i would say that um tim
because last time i was on here
it was i believe we just came off one of
the presidential debates and we were
even talking about in the show we were
like
we were like why would they even mention
the proud boys we have people that are
dying in this pandemic
you know we're giving them too much
attention and like i said on the left
media
it seems like any anytime we have uh you
know
anything uh regarding the right wing
stuff their problems are the easy
scapegoat but then
same thing on the right any violence
break breaks out antifa is a scapegoat
so it's like this is this is the
interesting thing to me when it comes to
news and conflict in crisis you have the
left
which has full control of cultural
institutions complaining about fringe
groups of a couple thousand people as if
it's the end of the world
and i'm just like sitting here like well
i mean the billions of dollars in damage
and destruction and
you know havoc that was reaped upon
regular people came from the left
the proud boys sure you can criticize
them but
why are these massive cultural
institutions
ignoring this you know what i mean why
i guess the way i'm putting it i'm
trying to i look at it as
should i really be concerned about a
group of a few thousand people
who you know talk smack on the internet
and go around and march and get drunk
and then sometimes fight antifa or
should i worry about
the thousands of people that are being
praised by mainstream media
who are being propped up by leftists and
they're they're comparing them to the
soldiers storming the beaches of
normandy
that's that's scary to me yeah they
ignore it it's not a left or right issue
it's
i guess the left likes there well it's
the same thing as um
with the blm movement you know it's it's
okay
if we want to get to the root of the
problem and we and we think that black
lives matter then
all suffering as as a result of any
violence
should be something that's deemed as bad
right and so it's the same thing it's
like instead of
addressing the full problem you just
choose this scapegoat that's really easy
oh police
you know okay it's all police all cops
are bastards
that's easy easy enemy this is why they
you know
they'll lump anybody who just agrees
with them as in right wing they'll say
they're all right wing or they're
conservative or far right
i think it was i think the young turks
called me right wing which is hilarious
i i disagree with you on why when you
support violence so i'm right-wing
i actually agree with them unlike a lot
of domestic policy and economic policy
so right wing and left-wing are
completely meaningless but this is it
for me i'm not a right-wing person
i've actually had people dming me and
they're like i can see the leftists and
like i talk about economic policy and
stuff like that especially
like my issue is when i take an
objective look at the media
and what's going on come on it's obvious
when they went out
and they marched in the thousands and
then it was i think it was university of
colorado said
black lives matter protests actually
slowed the spread of covid it's like are
you
kidding me dude come on any sane
rational person sees that that's
ridiculous but
they all had masks on even though there
were like 10 000 of them crammed into a
space there well no like at
these big projects they weren't wearing
masks it's impossible
no but looks good when that was going on
earlier in the year they weren't wearing
masks
yeah then later on they started saying
wearing masks wear masks but then we saw
them celebrate biden take the mask off
drink champagne
can so so they're calling everyone right
wing but what you're really getting is
regular people
who just see how absurd the news has
become
and they're just like okay that's fake
and then say well then you must be
right-wing
that's exactly where i fall i voted for
obama twice but now all of a sudden
you know you tell the truth and you're
you're right-wing interestingly you know
i'll mention this too you guys were both
in kenosha as well
yeah yeah correct you guys are you guys
are like some of the most consequential
journalists having been
on the ground at some of the biggest
moments of this past year yeah it feels
weird just uh
where's your pulitzer huh vince but i i
i i'm not
i'm not i'm not sitting here and being
like you guys are going to work no like
but seriously of of the journalists
we've seen what do we get the poulters
go to the people who just rag on cuomo
listen cuomo deserved that he deserved
it the emmy
i like the yummy i mean what whatever oh
yeah oh you see yeah
como gets he's got a shiny thing yeah he
gets the emmy and he's like writing a
book and he's a
new york times best seller for handling
the crisis it's it's insane but
yeah i mean it's just been it's been an
insane journey just kind of been
able to be you know documenting on the
on the front lines of
a lot of these kind of historic moments
and i mean it all really kicked off
uh you know that george floyd i believe
it was may
may 28th yeah the footage gets released
and
the whole world you know just turned
turned upside down i do want to mention
it looks like kron4 has removed
the article about the officer dying yeah
it's gone
so the the article that we had pulled up
you can see uh if
you pull it up the url says u.s capital
police officer dies after a violent
protest bringing death toll to five is
the url
and now it says the page you are looking
for cannot be found maybe he didn't die
the media posted fake news and we all
fell for it but i'll tell you something
if i think that that guy is injured
though yeah he got hit
and i think he's in very critical
condition so if matt gates comes out and
says
you know oh look antifa was actually
down there they boom they say it's fake
news
all that let's come out and say it's
fake news okay i won't use it
now we actually have a reporter from
kutv saying here's a blm leftist who was
actually storming the capital it's like
oh okay
so so there it's there's some truth to
this the mainstream media can put out
this big story
we're told we have to accept them as
being right and here we are
in real time they were wrong we opened
this show with this big news of an
officer dying
because we trusted the mainstream media
so what are we how do we navigate this
well i think i think that what we were
talking about earlier about
basically being able to scapegoat that
kind of smaller group
that's easier to put in a box that's
what happened after this you know
nobody wants to address the fact that
these people
you know who regardless of who they were
are angry about the results of the
election like
um so those people that we saw you know
battling cops was every single one
antifa i literally saw hundreds of
people battling with cops
calling them all q and q and on
supporters is
just ridiculous it's completely insane
and that takes away the real reasons why
they're mad which is
they've been locked down for six months
and then they feel that the election was
taken from
what if the reality is just that it was
predominantly trump supporters but
there's probably a decent you know
spattering of leftists who joined in
because they just don't like the
government
what if what we're actually gonna start
seeing is general populist
revolt you know it doesn't matter if
you're right or left
clearly this guy who stormed the capitol
building this blm guy is not a right
winger
what was he doing there why and why
wasn't he fighting with the right
he was actually along with him it's
capitalizing on the chaos just like the
looters you know
but they're not they're not protesting
anything they just want to get a free tv
i think it might become outright
establishment you know versus
outsider populist regardless of left or
right i mean we were talking about this
just
a few weeks ago on this show we were
telling you there's a big political
realignment
a lot of people on the right are being
disenfranchised with the back the blue
crowd
the back the blue crowd is becoming less
and less significant
more people are being disenfranchised
what's going to happen when again these
ingredients that we
were talking about that led to this
they're not being subsided
they're being added upon and then
what's what's going to happen moving
forward when the conditions get worse
the economic conditions are bound to get
worse
the lockdown conditions are bound to get
worse
the restrictiveness when it comes to
people's freedoms and liberties are
bound to get worse
what happens when you keep pressuring
more and more
on a public you know and again it's so
frustrating because
for for years i i've been calling it out
for years i've been seeing it
and everyone's like oh you're crazy
you're just hyperbolic and i'm like no
you guys don't understand the larger
ramifications
from what i've seen in my foreign
foreign reporting to what happened to
other countries
that same thing is happening here and
and and again
it's just absolutely insane to see it
happen in our backyard
also very interestingly the president of
the chicago police union actually came
out with a statement pretty much going
against
all the other establishment kind of
thinking around this and he said
that there was quote this is according
to him there was no arson
there was no burning of anything there
was no looting there was very little
destruction of property
there was a bunch of pissed off people
that feel an election was stolen
somehow some way that's the official
quote from the show
i was looting though uh yes there was
there's pictures of guys actually
stealing the podium
there you see that do you see the jokes
you see the joke though where it's like
the guy
decided to finally take a stand took a
political stand yes
literally and figuratively but but but
yet again the thing we have to realize
here
all the things that made this happen
they're they're still there
they're only going to get worse and i
think it is worth noting that while like
a couple of podiums were taken
at least that i saw or what i've seen
reported you know none of those precious
works of art were intentionally
uh vandalized it's just like they were
walking around the red rope
which was so fascinating people are like
wait wait wait wait hold on they just
stormed
the senate bills right but they're
walking down
or whatever i don't know there's the
meme people saying i'm just fascinated
with these people who stormed this
building and they're and they're walking
in line
somebody somebody tweeted i love when
our uh insurrectionist rioters
carefully walk around the velvet rope
you know yeah it was weird it was weird
i think
you know you see some of these videos
and there were enough
reckless rambunctious individuals but
decent amount of bumbling
you know bewildered individuals yeah
oh i didn't mean for you i was gonna say
there's rumors i guess that like people
are taking hard drives out of computers
or something
i don't know if it's true i seen the one
where it was the guy who like posted up
in nancy pelosi's office and he has
american flag then there's like another
footage of he's like outside and he has
her mail yeah
that's ridiculous i have nancy pelosi i
got to go to prison
but i was gonna ask do you think we see
something similar maybe not
the biggest that the same crop was
something similar on january 20 from
inauguration day
where the national guard is being uh
they're being kept deployed
right for i mean there's a curfew for
the next 15 days yeah wow
in washington d.c
now is a good time to leave town i'm
very upset because
i'm very upset because after 6 p.m you
can't get ubereat so i can't get my
mcdonald's so i got it
i got a breeze last night i got any
breeds last night yeah really i couldn't
get it from virginia you got to order
from the right place
they said essential workers and delivery
and stuff like that are okay i couldn't
get it on my added media it's it's a
reduce out you know i love more than
anything
the media exemptions essential how crazy
like these journalists get to like walk
around do whatever they want as long as
you're your press card and you can sit
back on media
well kind of until you get beat up by a
cop yeah
they do a curfew when you're walking
around and the cop sees you back press
where you know we're
we're covering everything we're here to
report on what a good job you guys have
done keeping everything safe and secure
and so we wanted to come out and just
get some some footage from our phone of
showing you guys how
this everything's safe so thank you
officer and you just keep walking oh
that's what i tried to do but all i
could get in was these are my
credentials yes sir
either way i'm talking about it's 8 p.m
the streets are empty and you as a
journalist are like i'm going to go out
and grab some food
and so you walk outside and you're
walking down the street you're going to
get your you know
you know crispy popeyes chicken sandwich
everybody loves and there's a cop and
he's like hey you it's curfew and you go
actually i'm a journalist here's my card
and they go have a nice day and they
will
privilege that's brilliant yes well
everyone else is locked in their house
they can't leave
journalists are are exempt but then
you're i mean what really what you're
doing is you're being a
piece of crap because you're abusing
your privilege what else is next so just
like but there's no real like
rules that can keep a crappy person from
taking advantage of stuff
right i mean in new york city i used my
press card to go to
gala dinners because i was hungry
sometimes you know and then
that was you're a bad journalist they
had really hey it happened i admit it it
wasn't
well there's the there's there's the
inverse one time luke used a
a a huffington post was it a lunch a
lunch card
yes as a pass a press pass and it worked
it was amazing amazing yeah
so so like well it said huffington post
on it exactly that makes sense so what
happened
it said luncheon on it and it didn't
even say press and i used it to sneak
into events
and then we trained someone well and
this was funny
this is insane we went to an event and
we knew people
having to post they gave us these cards
where it was like luncheon and you had
to walk in and like grab a sandwich and
grab a drink
but luke kept his and there was a point
where like someone said where's your
press card and he just has this big
ridiculous looking thing says huffington
post luncheon and the guy's like oh
thank you
because they know what huffington post
was they were like that must be it but
you didn't
the thing is you didn't tell them to
look at it no you you had no no this is
the thing you don't even have to say
anything
it's just all about your confidence and
your horror it's just like
well we don't say that what happened was
you had a bunch of press cards on one
lanyard yep and so the guy just took the
biggest one and looked at huffington
post and assumed like it must be good to
me and luke's like
whatever yeah says lunch on it that's
what i when i interviewed ariana
huffington and uh she wanted
me to work for the huffington post but
after i interviewed her she uh i was
very very disappointed
and very shocked to learn the questions
that i threw at her
about to learn that to learn that you
had been using her lunch card
i mean there's a ton of stories that we
could share also does anyone else find
it weird that the establishment went
from
you know defund the police to we need
more police we need more arrests in just
a matter of seconds when it would fit
amazing their narrative i mean can
anyone just call that out
as being how perfect nope just got
censored
how perfect was it that for a year
they're saying defund the police
and the democrats defend it saying it
just means reallocate funds
and then as soon as biden wins they're
like we need police where the police and
the left is in agreement
surprise and there's no push back and
there's no voices dissenting there's no
people saying hey hey what about what we
were
campaigning for what about what we were
fighting for what about all the protests
that we had
about this very specific issue and now
we're pro-police state because it fits
us because we're in power and they're
going to be using that power and the
inverse is true as well that it's funny
that also
trump supporters are like oh these cops
yeah i'm so mad
well they're burning the back the blue
flag so that's also another huge
kind of you know political
transformation that's worth noting
because
there's going to be disenfranchised
leftists who are still going to be on
that messaging
who are still going to believe in
defunding that police that are going to
be looking at them in a favorable way
he's just he's not defund biden's not
defunding the police he's just funding
a bunch of armed social workers to
enforce lockdowns well someone someone
tweeted something really hilarious
about what went down i think i retweeted
it they said in response
they were like after watching what went
down in the capital it's it's more
obvious than ever that we need to get
rid of all the capital police and
replace them with social workers
that's a really good point because
people are saying the protest was mainly
peaceful as well mostly peaceful i mean
truth be told it was mostly peaceful
there was no fire
it was mostly peaceful 300 or so people
out of hundreds of thousands went in the
building right
that's like what 99.9 percent peaceful
i'm not gonna play stupid games though
the people who stormed the capital set
set the stage and it was dumb
and when you get the same thing with
anti-fun they're burning buildings down
look
this is what i say about antifa if
you've got a bunch of people standing in
front of the federal building throwing
fireworks and explosives
and the peaceful protesters are like
well i'm being peaceful but i'm not
going to stop him
i'm like dude you need to leave or you
need to stand up it's day 95
right exactly we know what's gonna
happen here but i'm being peaceful
yeah and you're and the guy's hiding
behind you when the cop is looking for
who threw it
and they don't do anything about it so
it's look man i think
one of the biggest issues we have as a
society is that individual groups don't
hold their own accountable
cops don't want to hold other cops
accountable protesters don't hold other
protests accountable
they want each other held accountable
but they won't do it themselves so we've
seen more than enough instances
where there's like a cop who breaks the
law and then his partner lies for him
i've seen it in new york we saw with
that story where the cop shoots the guy
in the back
this is back in like north carolina the
guy was like they're trying to arrest
his black dude he runs away
cop shoots him and his partner lied for
him so these things happen again i'm not
stupid enough to say
all cops i'm just saying when that
happens you got to be like
he did it well like no the fourth estate
has to be like that right and that's the
role of the media
and now the media yeah they can look out
after their own but as
one media you know journalists should
have the right to free speech and to
report on
after curfew etc but right now we're in
a situation where if you're not if you
don't think like me
and you're a journalist then you are the
enemy and so
we're that's the one institution that's
supposed to keep the other ones in check
and that's it's not just the enemy
they'll beat the crap out of you if you
report on an event
that is is happening and you report on
it honestly if someone doesn't like that
truth
they'll beat the crap out of you and in
some places you could even face worse or
consequences with governments going
after you and this is the kind of
bigger worrying that that is in my
stomach because
just reporting on the truth is
detrimental
uh and that's the stage that we're in
right now no actually you are here
yeah well yeah this is a look you always
get these great shirts i know on point
so it's
so it's 1984 brave new world ray
bradbury 451
and it's a it's uh it's a diagram
well they're not burning they're not
burning books they're just deleting
tweets
but it's true you got the you got you
got the drugs to keep you happy you got
the the censorship from the government
and the big tech and you've got this
and well more than a big police state
boot uh you know and
you are here right here in the middle
pretty much welcome a little bit of
everything a little bit of everything
you know sprinkle a little
time to be able to get a little brighter
laugh yeah
this is history man this is you know
great
yeah i know you know what i think i
think we all many of us many many
many people are watching i know that
you're all between the ages of 25 and
34.
that's true uh that's like 30 of the
audience
and the rest it's it's typically 18 to
54 big chunk in the middle
we grew up in a golden age man where
everything was kind of chill i mean we
had with 911 we had war everybody got
trophies too right exactly yeah
it was like we played video games baby
we we uh live comfortably i mean go to
another country
and you'll see how comfortable america
has it i mean a lot of is it
isn't that kind of the reason why we're
seeing all this though on both sides is
that
we were the kind of the first generation
of americans who were like promised
more than we would get and then we're
like the kid who doesn't get the
cool toy yes maybe but i think it's
really about like
we're spoiled rich kids america is like
this super spoiled rich kid
it's like the the sweet 16 who's like
you got me a ferrari i wanted a
lamborghini
uh-huh that's what that's what that's
what i think i'm like man clean running
water
some places have laws where they have to
give you water if you ask for it
like if you're i think in arizona they
do that if you walk into like water they
have to give it to you
because it's like you know arid and
people could dehydrate and stuff we got
you know the poor we have we have uh i'm
not saying this to be mean but we have
overweight homeless people like
something's going on not now
admittedly we have a weird imbalance if
if we can't get a home to somebody but
we can over feed them so we can figure
some of these problems out
but that's saying something because i've
been to some countries where you've got
homeless starving people
so i think we get a generation
millennials
who have been raised with the utmost
comfort
and privilege and they're now being told
that they were going to be rock stars
and millionaires and celebrities
and they're mad they want more they want
something else and they don't realize
that you can just go
do it you know but i think the issue is
what do they want they want everything
they want more they want more than they
have and you know when it comes to
the issues of like healthcare for
instance i'm totally down with
you know providing a basic level of
coverage for for all people like you
break your arm you go to the doctor
they'll fix your arm but if you get a
more serious illness
we might have a cure for that this i
don't realize i've i've had arguments
with leftists about universal healthcare
and i say how do you deal with like you
know an extremely rare
genetic disease where the treatment the
cure exists but it's a million dollars
because this is a real story was in
louisiana the the government refused to
pay a million dollars for this extremely
rare genetic
disease treatment and i'm like sometimes
cures don't exist and you know i've
heard from a lot of people they've
argued back at me
no you're wrong scarcity is not real and
i'm like we haven't invented the cures
to every we haven't cured cancer
there's so many cancers we have we have
very little effective treatments for but
they just believe that you can snap your
fingers and give it yeah it's a
technology drugs are technologies and it
takes an incredible amount of money to
develop them
and so that's you know so i think i feel
like there's a lot of people who think
we deserve to have health care and i'm
like okay i agree i like the idea you
know i
like the fire department i like the the
police department they don't like the
police departments i don't know how you
solve that problem
you want universal security well then
you know get it i guess but
uh so they want universal health care
and i'm like how do you deal with the
fact that
there will always be an issue i think
for the most part we're we're struggling
to solve in terms of treating human
beings
long story short we are living safer
and healthier if we choose than ever
before
we have antiseptics we have antibiotics
we have tons of antibiotics
we can do organ transplants think about
someone 100 years ago they'd stub their
toe and get a little cut and go well i
guess i'm going to die you know cut the
foot off
and we have all of this wonder and
privilege and wealth it's one of the
best times ever
and there are people who are angry and
complaining and refuse and so
i think in the long run that fighting
ultimately leads to them having it worse
than ever yeah i mean historically we
are living in one of the best times in
recorded human history especially when
it comes to access to clean drinking
water especially when it comes to access
to food
education quality of life all those
things are skyrocketing up
but when it comes to our mental health
we are declining
abruptly in such a scale that it's
insurmountable
and the solution by the system is just
throw ssris and again
i don't even want to get into that
debate but there is a correlation it
doesn't mean
it it proves causation but there is a
correlation between the rise of social
media
and the decline of america's mental
health there's also a lot of fat
asses out there so that complicates the
whole medical debate out there
but but again this is why i've been
stressing censorship social media
the the people who have the voices that
are influencing us the most
the algorithms the timelines the things
that you are shoved to be a consumer the
thing that you are groomed to be the
thing that you are programmed by the
very special interest
to be is something that is detrimental
for
you and people need to realize it sooner
before later because
this mental health decline is leading to
a lot of mentally unstable people
and when you have a whole bunch of sick
lazy
fat incompetent crazy dumb people
you're you this is another recipe in
that big pile of crap
that i that i keep describing uh and
again we could keep throwing it in there
but but
we could all see it's there and there's
no way of cleaning it out
self-sufficiency man and then uh you
know tim since we're on this subject i
think it's really unique
like for me you know both of my parents
are from el salvador
we're in we're in the in the civil war
so i always actually grew up with
my dad just beating into my head of like
we are already like
we are already so rich we're already so
lucky to already be in the u.s so like i
always
grew up with that like appreciation for
like what we had so i think that was
kind of a unique
perspective to grow with immigrant
parents and getting that and then
you know my parents were like in the
civil war so they really made me
appreciate everything
here so i think for me that was like an
undercover blessing of like we you know
i never felt like we we
ever took things for granted even even
now i'm still like oh man i'm not
supposed to be here i could have been in
like an ms-13
um right now but i mean i'd be
interested to even hear from more kids
who are immigrant parents compared to
just
american kids with how they feel i think
i could have been in poland
at school slav squatting and again you
brought up an important thing i was
brought up also by immigrant parents
that brought me here to the united
states they were saying the same thing
you don't understand how lucky you have
to hold on to have so much freedom here
when you were in poland it was during
the soviet union yeah
i was born at the decline of the soviet
union i was still born into the soviet
union
and my parents fled my dad specifically
left and said this is
bull crap i don't like communism i don't
want my kid growing up in communism
i want the freedom that's portrayed in
movies i want to be in the mecca of it i
want to be in the center of it he chose
new york city
and he's having a hard time leaving that
place even though i keep telling him i'm
like man dude you don't understand
like you need to leave a place but he
still is envisioned by like this is the
country that saved me
from communism that saved me from a
totalitarian government that would
throw people in jail torture them or
execute them because their political
opinions were different
than the state that's something that
people don't realize
is a huge threat of happening right now
in the united states and unless we
i guess we stand up and understand
what's happening and actually at least
raise our voices
we're screwed this is our trajectory
this is where we're going leftist
governments that are left
unchecked and have no accountability
historically always get completely out
of hand
that's the story of poland that's the
story of the ussr
that's the story of of so many people
who have suffered tremendously
because there was no checks on power
there was no accountability
there was no one contesting a government
and now we're in a position
where again i mean do i even have to
point it out what's happening right now
with with the corporations the
mainstream media and the government all
in unison saying
more power for us and less for you
because we know what's better for you
and they don't well if you're and more
of your money and yeah but uh we should
go to super
chats and uh start taking some questions
from the comments
so let's see what everybody has to say
if you haven't already smash that like
button it really really does help
uh yeah seriously give us a good thumbs
up and subscribe at the notification
bell
if you're listening on itunes or spotify
leave us a good review and if you're not
make sure you check them out and you
know follow us there too because it
really does help
but let's see what we got here let's see
dragon hunt says so when is that
i'm a gorilla shirt going live i don't
know but soon
and uh i believe the graphic is almost
done and it's just a gorilla and he's
like you know hitting his fist together
saying i'm a gorilla and that's it
and that's the joke and then another one
says i'm a gorilla love yourself
because we want to be positive you know
gotta be positive about this yeah yeah
valentine's day benjamin says no ian no
peace
yes ian is wrong for the night he's
missed
no peace no racist ass police
he's in the house well there's no pop
stopping him from me oh man
wait what we got to think of a good
rhyme for the second person no federal
reserve
something about uh quantitative ease
what's that metal that he's obsessed
with
yeah yeah definitely go check out
ianette
at ian crossland yeah yeah he's john uh
we got another one no ian
no peace he gets a night off yeah come
on guys yeah i think i think by now
he probably would have brought the
federal reserve several times can
someone
can someone super chat the second verse
of that for ian no ian no peace
no quantitative ease yeah there you go
that's pretty good i like that
that's what the federal reserve does you
know the money all right let's see we
got
all right so this is an interesting
question crystal mac says tim what in
the world is going on
in that video of pence getting a coin
and rubbing elbows with nancy pelosi
if not today maybe soon thank you so
they have these things i forgot what are
they called challenge coins challenge
coins that's right
and in in the photo of nancy pelosi's
office you can actually see she has a
rack of them
challenge coins they're just
commemorative coins made by groups that
commemorate
them so i think someone gave me a donald
trump challenge coin yeah law
enforcement has a lot of them
yeah they're just aren't they just like
trinkets yeah i got an air force one
one from a journalist so basically it's
like a little coin and it'll say like
air force have an eagle on it
and there and it'll say like you know
usaf or whatever one i got was like
donald trump and it said
inauguration of the president 45 2017 or
whatever and it was like a picture of
the american flag on it or something
that's all it is i think i'm pretty sure
have you seen the video of pence you're
like
shakes someone's hand and then he looks
in his hand he's got a coin and then he
puts it in his pocket and he like smiles
and nods it's probably just a challenge
maybe it's like a clinton foundation
challenge coin oh yeah
probably no doubt welcome to the club
this one will get you to the island as
it was
look there's a whole bunch of them i've
seen journalists collect them
because like i know a lot of journalists
they'll go to events and they'll ask the
cop do you guys have challenge coins
yeah i gotta go well we do and like then
they'll get like you know fort
lauderdale police do you have any tim
me yeah yeah i said i got like a trump
one somewhere oh yeah okay so i when i
was uh um
i can't remember where i was at i was at
a trump rally someone gave me
an inauguration coin it's probably in a
box somewhere i didn't know what it was
i was like
what is this a coin they're like yeah
yeah it's just basically a piece of art
it's a metal thing you put it on a rack
or whatever yeah it's a collector's item
all right see gentleman's talk says the
guy died of a stroke
it could have just as easily happened to
him taking a dump
good point yeah heart attacks definitely
do when you're taking it yeah
is there any tear gas in the in the
toilet that could definitely like
elevate
a little bit so this is an interesting
one soul invicta says tim says that
violence achieves nothing that fifth
generational warfare is all in the mind
and yet antifa's been violent getting
their way
dems violent getting their way the
entirety of the human race
throughout its history violent getting
their way okay and i'm gonna i'm gonna
demonstrate it's very simple do it first
of all
the generation of uh warfare generations
evolved we went through
stodgy well we went through like you
know general fighting we ended up with
like people
marching on a battlefield towards each
other then we get guerilla warfare and
tactics change
and now the biggest uh you know factor
is cyber war manipulation
influence campaigns and people say oh
but antifa does this
antibodies finally get their way no no
you're mistaken they're not getting
their way because of violence they're
getting their way because they because
the mainstream media
the controller of influence defends it
or covers it up
when people saw what black lives matter
started doing after george floyd died
their support went
down even though the media was saying
peaceful protest
so yes i understand they're getting
their way but they're getting their way
in many instances not always
they're getting it because they're being
defended by those who control influence
that's why i always say it the most
effective protest is wearing a nice pair
of slacks and a button-up shirt and
shaking
shaking people's hands and smiling and
it's why you get these politicians who
who have
you know have you guys ever seen that
movie was it called bullworth
where the politician just like snaps and
then he's like you know they told me to
wear a balloon
yeah yeah yeah basically he gets
cornrows yeah
they're totally the best hook on that
what what to wear why to wear it they've
structured everything perfectly because
that's the effective way to garner
influence from the people and when they
do that they grant
their voice to you which give which
empowers them so look antifa goes out
does these things but it's
hurting them they if antifa went out and
it was all peaceful protests
they'd have gained 10 times as much it
is it is in spite of the violence
that they're succeeding the media is
covering up too much of it
it doesn't work all right let's see we
got let's just jump down for some more
well that's why the mainstream media
needs to hide it
but don't you think that they they kind
of failed in doing that because
yes and no because it happened at such a
larger scale that we don't even
understand there was other journalists
like michael tracy that went around the
country
yeah and told us that the scale was far
more severe
than what is originally reported or even
known this is this is seriously
michael tracy got in a car and just
drove to small towns and encountered
places that no one has ever heard of and
he was surprised to find there were
riots there
the media wasn't covering it they didn't
care didn't fit the national narrative
and it's in it's in spite of the
violence if
if the protests were just peaceful mass
marches
it would be it would have been i'll put
it this way i think the riots are going
to be a stain on history
and it's going to be recognized as very
you know people died but imagine if it
was just like millions of people across
the country in various areas
marching and that was all it was it
would be a golden moment of history this
big awakening of peaceful uprising
changes would have come but they've lost
the support they had before
george floyd was eighteen percent net
after the riots eight percent
it went down as i'm telling you man
times change technology changes and the
information age is something very very
different
it's no longer the era of like marching
in a building black the building's ours
therefore we're in charge of the
government it doesn't work that way
well everyone has phones so eventually
that information just it will get out
right as long as you don't live in china
you know what it could be too like if
you go back hundreds of years
the reason taking the building meant you
had the power is probably because the
currency was in it the hard gold and the
only way to get it was if someone gave
it to you
so you couldn't trade and so they're in
the building they're armed okay i'll do
what you say just give me gold
now it's all digital through your phone
take the building my phone my paycheck
still went through well
the records if you took the building you
had everything that happened beforehand
all right let's see jordan reynolds says
tim let's be honest our entire upper
echelon of politicians are corrupt on
both sides
only a few patriots exist in our
government they are a dying breed
how do we push forward when everything
we say is out of context and being
controlled
i don't have all the answers man i have
a i have a uh
semi short answer for that which is like
having been in dc for 12 years i think
what i was most surprised at working at
nbc was that there was this institution
of media that was built up around
you know bill clinton started the white
house press briefing and then if you
wanted to be a good reporter who got
questions in that briefing then you
better not ask jay carney a question
that right you know we'll get you
blackballed the next time
so over if that happens over the course
of 40 years then you guess
with this symbiotic relationship and the
the media who's supposed to put these
corrupt politicians in check
are themselves you know basically
throwing them a bone so i think
the the reality is look there's a
gigantic machine the way
the way i described it to occupy people
back in the day was you got a giant
skyscraper
and every day 300 million people are
building it bigger and bigger
and you're at the base complaining about
it and there's a lot wrong with it and
you're trying to knock it down with a
ball peen hammer
i don't know necessarily the answer is
but perhaps the the answer is to just
walk away from the building and go find
shelter somewhere else
maybe the reality is what we should do
is
vote with our dollars don't support big
companies like amazon and walmart
do what you can to support mom and pop
shops especially right now if you can it
might not be possible that's the crazy
thing
but then if you can't be more
self-sufficient try and figure out how
to take
how to be more sustainable don't run to
the store or to desperately buy toilet
paper at walmart
just figure out a way to you know deal
with that in some non
you know fighting with people in walmart
over toilet paper maybe the idea is to
move out of the cities
learn how to farm uh get a place in the
middle i mean so many people are doing
this getting away from these cities
going to the suburbs
i think the big thing that needs to
happen when people don't realize
it all starts with you you know you got
to clean your room before you try and
change the world
all right jordan peterson but that's a
good point it's a fantastic no i totally
i mean i
i say that all the time so think about
it this way imagine if every single
person right now who's
upset with the system said i'm not going
to participate i'm going to go do my
thing
we're going to go set up our own you
know like go to wyoming go to west
virginia go to idaho go to nebraska
and just find open land and just get
back to basics
stop relying so much on the system and
its comforts and realize like
we live in this super elite
air-conditioned clean water privilege
and we can probably do better and that's
a win-win for everybody
i think the challenge arises when people
are like i'm used to the comfort level
that i have now
but we're in a golden age you know i so
for me and maybe it's maybe it's just me
i'll tell you this
i've been homeless uh i've slept in cars
before
i could be you know just in my van down
by the river happy
with the experience just chilling just
in a van down by the river go fishing
and
you know it's it's my freedom that i get
my most of my value from now i
understand if you have a family it's
probably much more difficult than to
just say
you know to do it so the issue
ultimately is
there's probably no good answer i
certainly think
stop voting stop like stop voting for
democrat republican
and vote for politicians who reflect
your values sometimes it's a republican
it really is
uh you've got you got rand paul you know
i think he's he's very liberty but he's
in the republican party
you get politicians who run in that
party and so you vote for him
but maybe it's just you know i'm i've
always been an advocate of voting for
the person you believe in not just
democrat or republican
it's how you end up in this mess like
you said it just create this system over
time where a symbiotic relationship
relationship emerges and maybe the
reality is we've spent
40 years getting into this situation and
it's gonna take 40 years to get out
and it starts with you saying i'm not
gonna vote for the republicans or the
democrats i'm gonna vote third party
um or a fourth party or fifth or just
i'm gonna vote for the name the write-in
the person i believe in
and they might not win but for me i
don't care a wasted a vote
a vote vote for the democrat or
republican because you fear one of the
other in my opinion is a wasted vote
because look what you get now look what
you get now the democrats control
everything congratulations
the system isn't going to work this way
forever and you just need to go vote
stop voting for the lesser of two evils
and stop depending on other people to
solve your problems i think that's the
biggest one
now you said you would be happy if you'd
be down by the river in a van
i'd be happy with a press credential
i'll eat good that's all i need but it's
because of people's
temperament it's your attitude that
essentially matters and i think you
taking your life
back and understanding that it's in your
control in your hands
your actions dictate every single thing
your imagination
is the creation of you uh when you start
understanding the true power
you have and start living it then
everything magically happens you were
mentioning the flow state i mean that's
something that i've been studying
looking into and many people
look at it as the key to success and
their prosperity
and if you don't know what that is just
look into it yourself check out some
books there's a lot of books but
think and grow rich that's the key i
read that one
that's a good one too so that such that
hegel called it was dazing which is like
when you're in your work state
and you're like doing that which you
were on put on earth to do
like be putting food on your table for
your family through whatever job but
it's yeah dozen interesting i think we
got to get back to
being independent and self-sufficient
like you just said luke you know
stop had relying on other people quote
um he said everyone is trying to run the
country no one wants to leave their
family exactly
and stop attaching your personal
happiness to what donald trump says on
twitter yeah
yeah i thought that was pretty i thought
that was pretty powerful
yeah it made me just we need more stoics
yeah people who built careers
by having all these notifications set up
so that as soon as trump tweets
they get the notification they can
respond right away man you need to find
something to do in
we got daniel maxwell says pence
requires all factions involved to desire
peace
violence occurs when one of the factions
decides oh i'm sorry peace requires all
factions involved to desire peace not
pence
violence occurs when one of the factions
decides to use force to get what they
want
war happens when one of the other
factions chooses to defend themselves
right and that's i guess why things are
getting scary man
yeah andre beltran says walter journal
just posted trump should resign to avoid
a second
second impeachment i thought people knew
it didn't completely go through the
first time
trump will not be i everything's on
pence right now
25th amendment requires mike pence to
initiate
some kind of removal then there's a vote
impeachment requires mike pence to break
the tie
wait but here's here's my question is
like okay so there's like two weeks left
now
less than two weeks yeah less than two
weeks is the point
is the point here anything to do with
like insurrection and the safety
of people in the country or does it have
to do with tarnishing
tarnishing and stamping out the legacy i
think that's what
trump's it could also be another factor
is i believe if he
is removed by the article 25 or if he's
in peace the second time he
either or that he can't run for a second
term and i i think that
that would that's also playing our world
mark levin yeah yeah
i know i i was reading something that
that's also playing the fact that they
don't want
trump to run in 2024 because i mean they
still know that he still has that
you know a big hand in that populist
wave on the right so
we got a good one here from bones he
says what happened last night has me so
conflicted
but what i do know is that all of us
need to take a chill pill and it's time
to
primary out everyone and yes yeah
i agree 100 great comment uh right on
nail on the head
but i also think now is the opportunity
for these people and all their anger and
74 million
to stop voting republican okay listen
people keep saying but if you don't vote
for the republicans then the democrats
went well they won congratulations
they're all here
you could have at least started
something new that represented your
values
and restored faith in the system in a
much you know better way and
takes investment i think the issue is
too many people are scared of the other
so that's why it's democrat republican
democrat republican
that's that's that's the only way we end
up going that's why i mostly didn't care
to vote for the most part
but i thought trump had some things that
were gone all right let's see what we
got here
one individual says that um is
advocating for the peaceful secession
from the union but i don't think that's
possible
no you know a lot of people have said
peaceful divorce you can't i don't see
that wait who's seceding from who though
like there's that meme about the united
states of canada and jesus land
oh okay like the blue states and the red
states just like
you know our dividing line yeah it's a
really interesting point mike cernovich
brings up everybody wants to
to lead the country isn't it simple to
just be like how about we let red states
be
you know have their own laws like just
ease up on the
federal rights yeah like 10th amendment
go back a little bit towards states
rights
you know just so people go back to the
articles of confederation and everybody
has their own money
and there's like 80 different kinds of
money that'd be awesome
i would like that let's see let's grab
some super chats here
let's see uh leor engelstein says i was
there in the beginning but before it
became super crazy the switch happened
when the news of the pence letter came
out
i sent richie some photos of paperwork
that was taken from mcconnell's desk
crazy what up that's not that's bad
shout out to leon vegas but i've i've
heard that people were saying that
everybody was chill and then once the
letter came out from pence saying he
would not support the president they
were just like i'm mad and pence didn't
need to release the letter
he could have said he what he didn't he
didn't release the letter he didn't need
to oh right i know that's the thing that
added
so much fuel to the fire yeah you know
maybe that was the letter that he
received at bush's funeral and he just
took it out and then he finally
oh that conspiracy
he could he could have just said i am
going right now and i'm going to hear
the evidence and see this vote counted
properly and i will do what's right by
the people of this country and they
would have been like come on pence come
on pence that would be and that would
have been boring and all day with
nothing happening
you know the trump supporters waiting
outside clapping and getting ready and
then pence would be like biden wins
and then by then it's late people are
going home and things chill out maybe
i think it was already too late i mean i
already think no
i think threw the hot potato at him
and he was stuck in a situation where he
just had the u.s president say that the
election is
in his hands right before that moment
which was a very weak move let's be
honest here
v cydia says ashley babbitt served for
14 years in the air force with four
tours of duty in iraq and afghanistan
and she died on the floor in the same
place that sent her over there
that is that that's exactly what i said
it's for her to do all of that
to die in the u.s where's all the
protesters
about unarmed people being shot you know
when open but they
but the thing is like why didn't we
storm the capital when we found out that
the iraq war was a quagmire
that was my question that's why i you
know
don't even get me started yeah seriously
that's why that's my thing people
started talking about area 51 again
oh my gosh kelty says this is not about
trump
this is about covet lockdown the devils
find work for idol
idol hands yeah people were just
you know all right let's see we got here
trying to go we got so many super chats
thank you guys nicholas osborne says tim
luke lids i am eternally grateful for
what y'all do keep on keeping on this is
true this just truly is a land of
confusion
it is tough and we're trying to figure
things out huh but uh don't forget ian
ian's normally here he's just he's
out today jake says
stop clutching your pearls like the
rebels cost trump anything
all they did was stop the republicans
from pretending like they cared about
certifying
democrats will do what they always plan
to do and those who would leave
who would leave us now never had the
sand to stick around betsy devos
resigned
like that was huge for trump and the
trump supporters you know and a lot of
other people have resigned too
i just think i i think it was it was a
net negative i mean even in terms of
life loss was obvious
what was gained that's that's the real
like what
was won by that nothing i mean optics
was well horrible
yeah we lost there's always there's
always uh the quote from iron man
you guys see iron man 2 uh ivan vonko
if you make god bleed then there will be
blood in the water and the sharks will
come
i think the last thing you want is for
this country
to be shown to be weak especially at a
time when china
is advancing yeah in iran right now
like of all the times to to expose
weakness
in this country that was yikes man
that's not even about trump or democrats
that's about the fact that china's doing
beaching drills and we've got joe biden
in office
easier to get it's easier to get in the
united states capital than it is to get
into a bar when you're 18 years old
yeah well i don't i mean i mean you had
hundreds
i trust me i tried to do that and i
didn't get into that bar but
i got him you've got hundreds of
thousands of people trying to mdc
and people are freaking out like all the
money we spent on security and they were
able to breach it
that is the it's like the worst possible
time for this to happen
all you have to do is take a towel and a
bunch of ice
and you could have gone into any bar
through the back door at any point well
there you go
that's the way to do it t list says tim
i love your work i'm considering
pursuing a career in journalism but
seeing the state of the media makes me
question if my work would always be
restricted
is journalism a career worth pursuing in
our time
i don't know what do you say
it should be but everything is
de-incentivizing people
from doing it because it's hazardous
it's becoming more and more dangerous
and the likelihood of you as an
independent person making it
is becoming harder and harder especially
with all the censorship efforts
and the mainstream media just getting
the dominant uh search results the
dominant headlines the dominant
algorithm feeds
but but that's something that i don't
want to say i want to say do it go for
it because you can make it
if you truly believe in yourself the
odds are stacked against you but when
you do make it
it's going to be worth it so much more
and you're going to be so much more
important than you even realize
yeah and if you're asking yourself that
question then i think that you're going
in with the right mindset which is
you know you're doing it for the right
reasons so all right we got a very
important super chat here from david
brady says hey tim donated ten dollars
earlier but couldn't attach my message
loving tim cast irl i heard you play
magic the gathering how much to come
play with you
actually so we're setting up the new
website it is it's coming along we'll
get it when we get it
we're going to have a vip members
section and there's going to be
we're going to do events so there will
be like limited ticket sales for members
and the general idea is if you are a
member of the podcast you get exclusive
content you get access to the show
but then when we do events there's a
very limited set of tickets available
for people to come
to our outdoor events it's kind of cold
right now but then
you know we've got the the new uh if
you've seen my instagram videos the
garage setup
so we're gonna do uh you know music and
stuff and it'll be really small
especially because of covid but this
will be like a really exclusive perk for
first-come first-served members so it's
coming it's coming and it's not going to
be based on money
we had a conversation about like you
know how do we do tiers for members and
the obvious one is like maybe if you
give a bunch of money you can come and
i'm like
and then predicating like your ability
to come hang out with like how much
money you have that's not cool i don't
like that idea
i'm too lefty for that stuff nah workers
of the world unite right
so my thing is like and i guess the only
the alternative is kind of like a first
come first serve which means
we'll send out a notice like hey members
we got 10 tickets and then boom they're
all sold
and then you can come hang out it is
what it is you know we we
tr try our best but some things are just
resources are finite right
all right let's see we got here meridian
forest
says i had a lot of pride and faith when
i joined the military not for the
country but for the people
and now i can't really see myself
supporting either the democrats or
republicans
because of the people i'd be standing by
i have always felt that way especially
like i grew up with the iraq war you
know what i mean
and i was surprised because my i i've
got you know on both sides of my family
military
and uh then i've got my you know my
brother was in the army and my sister
married to the army and i'm just like
but with everything i've seen i was like
why would someone want to do that
that's that's the challenge you know
i've heard good answers i'm not going to
put on like no i'm 34 so of course i've
grown up from being you know 15 or
whatever
but it was always crazy to me that we
could see the problems we could see the
corruption and you're going off to some
you know foreign country where there was
no wmds and it just felt like a rip-off
you know and who was supposed to keep
uh us from invading you know who was
going to call that into question the
media
and why didn't they do it msnbc was just
as for the war as cnn new york times is
like a pr
pr for the iraq war man
maddie says i don't condone violence but
people are sick of being smeared while
black lives matter gets quote in defense
of looting
i was there i went to support trump not
because i thought results would change
heard a guy say he was glad conservative
finally doing something people are fed
up
it's emotional man that's that's the
challenge
i criticize you know there's an activist
guy i knew from occupy and he said
smashing a bank window does nothing and
it hurts your cause but it really feels
good to the person who did it
and i'm like then why do it and he was
like people aren't smart enough to
organize to figure out how you
effectively target the corporations you
think are oppressing you
so instead they want that immediate
emotional release of attacking a symbol
of that oppression
and i was like that was very very smart
and that's it that's the federal
courthouse too in portland
right exactly what was the point of
going there storming the capital didn't
do anything
it didn't accomplish anything but i'm
sure people were like i'm angry and i
want to you know attack a symbol but
like
but it's just you know what man
logic versus emotion it's a big big
challenge for people
and ultimately this just created a
pretext for some new
you know ridiculous security bill more
police forces
they're not well at least it ended to
fund the police i suppose but
i mean i've never been a big fan of
militarized now i would imagine now
with any future demonstrations or
rallies or speeches in dc
i mean they're going to have that u.s
capitol building guarded
i mean you're not even able to step even
on the on the sidewalk steps of that
bill i guarantee they're going to have
it
but that's what we said about the white
house when they almost pulled them
jackson statue
and then it's like okay well another
symbol is the capital so
don't you think you maybe should protect
that one too in these
these times it's it's negligence to the
point of like i can't even comprehend it
no idea what they were thinking
but this is i mean this what happens to
a society when the ruling class and the
oligarchy is going to keep
smashing on on on regular working
americans they're going to stand up i
feel like it's
it's like when you trap an animal in a
corner we're seeing that right now but
you know who's holding the billionaires
to account the washington post
yeah i feel good about that yes yeah
uh-huh yeah because
it's owned by a robin hood type guy
named jeff bezos right who has no
connections to the cia
at all i love that guy all right eight
text and says no comment don't i did not
say that
says richie i know what you're doing
wearing that shirt you mock me
wife and i are happy y'all are safe take
care brother yeah
what do you what are you doing it's a
point break it's patrick swayze and
keanu reeves
this one says uh that's that's bodhi
they call him the bodhisattva on the
back it's a different quote
when do we get to go back to talking
about you know like movies yes
it's the lockdown it's it's making
everybody your cabin fever and can we go
to the movie theater yes please
well if you're in west virginia um you
can go to the movie theater
interesting point yeah the funny thing
is like there's a lot in west virginia
they have a mask mandate
and you walk in without a mask and no
one does anything yeah you know
i have a mask i had this really cool i
was bringing up someone sent me a masks
a little beanie on it
so i wear it but you'll walk in you'll
see nobody cares and it's like some
people will be like they'll avoid
somebody's not wearing a mask i'm like
that's very west virginia you know what
i mean like you see somebody not wearing
a mask
instead of going up to them and yelling
at them putting yourself at risk
you say i'm gonna avoid that person you
know what i mean i mean
smart right it's the opposite in
california i tell you that
they scream at you yeah you get points
it's like they want to get sick
rusty shackleford says tim poole has
been yelling into the void of the
internet for months at the establishment
and the traitors
now he is acting like a coward when
people act
uh yeah you know right now tim poole
it's funny that i'm like
here's what wins hearts and minds in a
fifth generational warfare context and
allows you to win elections
and then they're like yeah but we want
to break a window and i'm like but i
criticize people who break the windows
you may say that i'm railing on the
establishment i railed on antifa why
because they went around smashing
windows and destroying businesses and
then when the cops came out and violated
the constitution
i railed on the cops for violating the
constitution it's about principle
there's an effective strategy to to
solving your problems and
this ain't it so forgive me if my
principles remain
uh for the most part static when these
things go down
all right let's see we got here eric
miller says
i think it's like people handling
substances differently people handle
adrenaline differently your brain works
and uh an overclocked pc versus
everybody else just mentally crashes
oh in reference to our like time slowing
down yeah yeah yeah i think
there's a lot of people who just they
just they freak out in their brain just
like me it can't work
and there are some people that just like
heightened senses everything
slows down you can see everything it
becomes weird crystal clear it's just
like
matrix you know baltimore it's super
cool
you poke it and it just like floats away
in your life it also depends on the
situation and circumstance because
an individual who could have that kind
of matrix response could also have a
panicky one later on
yeah so there's incidences of both of
them happening
that's also you know a keanu movie as
well i know kung fu
yes so in reference to my comment about
you know the the violence uh 400 years
ago
rez says here's a few in the last years
ukrainian armenia
kyrgyzstan georgia russia belarus
macedonia serbia bosnia moldova romania
and they all had
they all lead to change is what's going
on in in many of these countries
like a positive thing right now russia
has been i mean i guess
the soviet union was more of an economic
collapse luke what was that
it was just like this it was it was uh
it was the drop of participation so many
countries
just decided not to participate anymore
not to feed into the system
and you had protest general strikes not
just in poland but also
around all all around the soviet bloc
with countries saying we're just not
going to participate
and of course the the soviet union was
going out of money and there's a lot of
different
political strategists including a very
excellent
interview by g edward griffin with a kgb
agent that talks about a larger kind of
strategy here which also could be at
play
but but again all it took was
individuals again some of the protests
work some of them were violently crushed
down
they protested again and uh
how about libya you got yeltsin though
like right wasn't it yeltsin
like he was pizza crap and they just
gave all the money to the to the
oligarchs who control the oil of course
and
and people talk about ukraine but the
oligarchs are still in control
exactly like so oh so the exact
president fled to russia
and now it's the same people who have
always controlled things by force
so you had the french revolution you got
napoleon fantastic yeah right and so
that's what i always tell people like
when you get when i see these antifa
people saying like once we're in control
we'll create a better world and i'm like
you think you're justified in hurting
people to get what you want
that's not going to change once you're
president you're just going to use it on
a larger scale
so it's difficult it really is i'm not
like it's easy
but i think about some of these
countries and i think about what you
just said
it's confidence in the system it can't
exist if you if you walk away remember
here's that tree house of horror
simpsons where the guy plays the song
just don't look because the
advertisements came to life
and then all you got to do is look away
from the advertisement and then it does
no longer alive
people also forget that like same thing
that we were talking about earlier with
drugs
government is a technology that's been
like developed over
so many generations and thousands of
years and like you can't just be like oh
actually my idea that i came up with
while i was sitting on twitter is much
better
so we're going to overthrow the
government i don't know
braveheart oh 484 says the left has no
idea what a civil war will mean to the
right
the problem is the left is doing what
every tyrant has done in history
what happens when the militia show up
the left believes anyone who disagrees
with them is evil and then uh 50 swm
const first i'm not super familiar with
what that means i assume it's a military
thing or something
but uh i agree and this is something joe
rogan said that the people who are
clamoring for revolution and the
the anti-foot carries banners revolution
nothing less they they don't understand
what happens
when the actual guys who have seen
combat
are forced out because you broke up in
the floodgates like people don't realize
isis is what happened in iraq i mean
that's that's the other thing i was
going to say about the violence thing
like how's it going for syria
you know libya libya you know the u.s
kind of
caused a lot of problems but early early
on the protest in libya
ultimately led to this intervention
early on the
protests and uprisings in syria what we
saw were the rebels pick up arms and
they said well they're shooting at us so
we're gonna shoot back
then isis so it's like perhaps
there's no real easy answer and perhaps
sometimes the conversation stops but
i'll say in reference to a lot of these
countries
yes maybe we don't have to go go back so
far but the reality is the united states
is
very very different especially today the
information age is
new it's very very new the internet is
what 26
years old-ish from when we actually got
like aol and copies well i think you go
back to like 1989 with compuserve or
whatever
and then like you had internet on dos
and stuff for those that are familiar
with it so we've really had
i think 2007 the advent of the smart the
the popular smartphone the iphone now we
have all the basic same phone structure
of
watching movies watching videos reading
tweets and that's changing everything
and now when you go out and you hurt
someone everyone kind of dislikes that
and they learn real quick
we talk about like false flags and stuff
in the military the gulf of tonkin
incident
it's very difficult to pull these off
now because everyone's got footage and
photos of everything
sure you know there's still tricks and
techniques but the reality is
information has changed the game
dramatically it's cool i think it's cool
we don't gotta get violent anymore
you know some people are and they're bad
people but also on the other hand with
social media it's creating more mental
illness which is driving people
yes exactly exactly let's see uh
i elite says shout out to the 1984 level
stuff
wanted to donate just in case they
erased the video your guests are top
knock tonight cheers guys oh we got some
you know legit journalists who are on
the ground covering this stuff you know
that's how we do let's see
we got a positive comment about tulsi
gabbard where did that go oh yeah it
just jumped
so uh so when we get too many super
chats it just bounces and then it's
great
oh no it went away they said but i can't
remember who it was
they said tulsi gabbard hit the nail on
the head with her latest interview
but the specifics are gone all right
jessie
misagion pronouncing your name wrong
probably tim how dare you quote the
worst
mcu movie literally the only time i've
heard someone quote iron man 2.
that's mickey rourke though isn't that
the character's name i mean he's a good
actor at least
i told you you liked him what i told you
you liked iron man
what do you mean iron man iron man too
yeah yeah and he's fighting with ivan on
ivan vancouver
yeah yeah yeah yeah what you're saying
i'm just saying you really like iron man
that's all i'm saying captain america is
cool too okay he's just trying to make
it seem like i was on the side of the
corporatists with the captain america
civil war thing
i think it's i think it's maybe because
you were like again
too personal defense sitting and giving
you an explanation of the pros and cons
listen marvel already sold out to china
so
yeah seriously find a new comic disney
yep
jared gilmore says the only question i
have is do uh
it is do we get trinidad pressure
everyone keeps saying
tronolim manona pressure but he said
truan and nana shabba the pressure yes
of course
i went through it a million times man
that's impressive yeah
wonderful use of time ben
busher says it's really easy to say
violence is wrong and storming the
capital is wrong when you haven't lost
your job
and in fact prospering from the current
crisis love the show just disagree
that's a fair point no i i i i really
good point i i i
i i i disagree well i still think that
it's it's
people in the media still have jobs in
fact
more people are paying attention to the
media because they're they're stuck in
home so it's
easy to you know to denounce anything
that's going on as a result of
um this unrest yeah we don't know his
pain we don't i will say
easy is a good point it's not like i'm
uh
suffering you know what i mean i think
we were doing actually a lot better
before the lockdown started and there
was a big hit because when restaurants
close advertisers disappear
a massive portion of ad rates are due to
local businesses advertising their
services and then when they got shut
down like
you could see it on youtube everybody
got hit really bad but truth be told my
company is not suffering
you know that's the difference it's uh
we're doing well here so i respect that
point
but i think the the thing being missed
there is
just because it might be hard and you're
suffering under the lockdown
doesn't make storming the capital the
solution it doesn't make it work
and my thing is and this is just me and
i know some people don't agree but i'm
gonna tell you what i think
i would personally if i saw the system
breaking down
and you know there's the the democrats
have won the election trump has won so
that's the direction it's gone the
election
you didn't get your way i'd rather go
farm
and if if i can't work i will survive
for myself
and i think that's something about you
know growing up and being homeless and
being on the south side and being poor
i have no expectations from the system
to support me in any way
in fact i just think typically it's a
detriment in some capacity so i'll rely
on myself
if i need food i got to get food it's
harder when you have a family that i get
but maybe what needs to happen is people
need to realize you might have to live
like humans had to live you might have
to farm
build your own stuff trade and be
self-sustaining and be independent
and not sit there and be like when will
the government allow me to run my
business again
because maybe they won't and maybe the
elections
didn't give you the outcome you wanted
because the democrats want the lockdowns
i mean joe biden campaigned on locking
down heavily
and fauci and bill gates have both said
normalcy won't come back until 2022.
when all these people vote for this then
what it's you know what do you do other
than fight for yourself i guess
it's not easy and there's no good answer
wear a mask stay inside and shut up
but then when you run out of food like
eventually you have to leave and go
order it on amazon no i mean like if you
have no money you can't pay your rent
yeah i'm not hear you at a certain point
you can't you've got sync button on you
i love how they're just dumb and clumsy
yeah chilling with me
uh odra noel uh zenitram says china is
vulnerable right now
they're requesting grain from the
surrounding countries around them and
trade war with aussies led them to
running out of coal for their steel
production
they're taking firewood and coal from
their citizens to keep up with steel
production
yup well they they they went after the
aussies yeah well that's another thing
we were discussing with china on censor
tiers that
china is not this huge big mighty empire
there's someone that is supported by the
u.s establishment but also
a country geopolitically not in a good
position with lack of
really important resources that they are
desperately trying to get right now
don't mess with the aussies i gotta
agree with this one ted the second says
the memes on ifunny right now
about all of this are on fire the exact
opposite of what cnn and others are
saying
the voice of the people well i agree
that there's a bunch of hilarious memes
like the one where it says
2020 was a weird year and then it says
six days into 2021 that's the viking guy
as president of the senate now banned on
facebook now banned on facebook
because fun is verboten sorry
not allowed only fear todd mastin says
luke i will buy you an i am a gorilla
shirt if you get me one of those that
you have
um maybe what kind of gorilla shirts do
you have well no
we're making the yeah the one we're
making yeah maybe it's probably gonna be
ready soon
it's right we just need the graphic
design and then the uh i am a gorilla
lover
competing with me now in my t-shirt
business tim what do you mean we have
t-shirts pinned right now that's too
young
i just figured this out because uh
youtube's been like on the fritz
they've changed something and like weird
things keep happening yeah we had the
other day
a six and a half hour live stream yeah
of nothing
just up here we've done uh
accidentally live streamed a hot mic in
our house
really for how long i'm not going to say
when cause then
you know people will find it and you're
saying all this really nasty it wasn't
that bad but
we were just like staying just really
just dumbs just being idiots
people were like trying to listen to
donald trump and they're just listening
to like a bunch of people
in the newsroom that's amazing yeah but
uh i just figured this out
i was like clicking around nice as a
merchandise thing and it says you can
pin a shirt and it's the hrump shirt and
i was like oh okay so i did it maybe
we'll sell a bunch of those but once we
get the gorilla one we'll put it up i am
a gorilla
it's literally just a gorilla saying i'm
a girl i have it's funny i guess
people really like it there's nothing
about it it's literally silly
that's it it's it's people are gonna
wear this shirt
and it's gonna be a gorilla like with
his fists like this says i am a girl and
people are gonna be like
okay there's no political message or
anything i love it it's great chill
yeah i mean haram if i say is really
good too also no big political
advancement
just just fine what's that referencing
so when i i uh periodically i'll make a
rice
i say i got you my references to the
establishment
i got it now we'll see i thought it was
like harambee's brothers
no no so like the joke i make is you'll
see like nancy pelosi will see a trump
supporter don't you go haram if i say
like you know how dare you and so then
someone made them
it's awesome well maybe we do a gorilla
shirt that's harambe's brother and he
says haram i say perfect
harambe shows would do well but youtube
for some reason took away my ability to
have
my shirts on youtube first for some
reason yeah i don't know why
why when you're done
so big boss i have to apologize you said
please read my last super chat i think
it got skipped
no and i i apologize but we have so many
super chats that the youtube feed
actually skips and jumps
and so i'm trying to scroll through but
it's really really
difficult stanky
i'm not going to read your name stankly
says tim as much as i agree with moving
away from cities i implore you to exempt
the crazy jurassic eden that is florida
is florida
florida is one of those last bastions of
the american dream because a lie
no i'm not reading that last part what i
want to know now there's a reference to
drugs
but uh i briefly lived in florida the
problem is no one goes outside
i lived in miami you can't no one goes
outside swimming i was supposed to be in
florida i still might be in florida
so by the way they don't go outside
because it's always like 90 degrees with
maximum humidity
but when it rains it is awesome like
every day it's like a type like it's
like a
a monsoon i'm outside and it's just like
crazy
but in miami you drive around no one's
outside except for january and february
and all of the windows of all of the
businesses are drenched in condensation
because the ac is on full blast and the
humidity is maxed out
so like you drive around and you don't
you don't see people you go to miami
beach and there's tons of people
but just driving around in the miami
general area i remember
wanting to go out and skate and it was
just so miserable because you'd go out
sweltering and humidity and park would
be empty
but in january and february that's when
it was okay
that was the one time let's see keyboard
warrior says love you luke
i love you too thank you oh here we go
tyler y says tulsi
has an interview with dave rubin
yesterday when the mayhem was going on
think the full interview dropped sunday
oh cool very interesting i think tulsi
is great
timothy vick says tim and friends can
capitalism exist without devolving into
an oligarchy
what protections could prevent it
constitution
yep an actual open market that's not
bastardized by government disagree
correct
a vibrant that's okay public discourse
there you go
free speech absolutely let's see
brian quill uh quillin says farming
isn't cheap
just a combined cost 750 000
a combine yeah seven hundred yeah i went
to a bunch of farms and talked to them
and that's hundreds of thousands of
dozen equipment but i'm not talking
about farming
and mass scale i'm talking about you and
your family
farming growing your own food i mean i
had chickens once they're great
they just you walk outside and they just
they're standing you've got chickens in
dc actually we've been looking into it
but you can get chickens
you should get chickens at the office
sure they like eggs
that's actually a good idea they like
that's a good idea
chickens lay eggs you know they do they
exactly that's correct so it's really
great you walk outside and the chickens
they they like the chickens i would have
the noise they would make because they
would go like
right when they pop one out no no no no
no
is that what the young kids are calling
it people say people say that they
they
what they don't realize is that chickens
make a bunch of different noises and the
ones we i had would walk around going
like
and they like whistle and like they do
yeah and then we would go outside and
they'd have a little thing they'd be
sleeping and then we'd walk in and they
would get up and they'd look at us and
there'd be eggs and they'd be like yeah
and then we'd go and make eggs for
breakfast it's awesome
but yeah you can do that you can have a
bunch of chickens running around doing
chicken stuff
they just make eggs and eaten the eggs
stink bugs but
it is it is not that simple you need the
the layer the protein feed for them you
need the special lights for winter and
stuff
but if you were gonna sustain your
family you know i kind of feel like
the way i always describe it if i was in
the middle of the woods
with nothing but a pointy stick that's a
net positive
you're not completely with nothing you
know i think most people assume they got
to have clean running water access to
healthcare their tv
and their showers and their
refrigerators and i'm kind of like give
me a pointy stick and i'm doing well and
if i'm in the middlewoods with nothing
i'll make a pointy stick and that's how
we start and then you start building a
house and you find water and then you go
from there and you like rely on yourself
man well people need to realize it is
extremely difficult
to farm even during the time i spent in
new hampshire we just had a little plot
that little plot took a lot of care and
maintenance
it's it's a lot and that's why a lot of
people who do end up
working a lot don't want to really share
it with other people and are naturally
more conservative
yep all right let's see dan saw f says
thank you thank you for all your hard
work everyone have a beer on me i
appreciate it thanks man
let's see what is that one um
geek oasis says please let me know where
i can get luke's shirt
at oh thank you very much thank you so
much for asking first
you could get my shirt and support my
voluntary efforts here
by going to we are change.org forward
slash shirts
so we are change.org forward slash
shirts get this one get everyone i wear
i pimp it i pick out all my merchandise
on on all the shows so whatever you see
me wearing we probably sell it we got it
we got to get one of those to put on the
wall i'm not even i'm not even kidding
that's like i mean that's where we're at
right now i know
you know people need to really like
realize it well
uh we've been uh quite a bit over as we
often do the show's supposed to be a
two-hour show but it became a
two and a half two and a half long line
yes or somewhere so uh
so if you haven't already smash the like
button subscribe at the notification
bell you can follow me on twitter and uh
twitter instagram parlor at tim cast and
you can check out my other channels
youtube.comtimcast
and youtube.comcastnews and
we're live monday through friday at 8 pm
check us out on itunes and other
platforms do you guys want to mention
uh your socials and you're working all
this stuff sure uh richie mcginnis
uh r-i-c-h-i-e-m-c-g-i-n-n-i-s-s
on all platforms a lot of ends and a lot
of s's two i is two ends and two s's yes
yes so hori ventura field correspondent
daily caller
ventura report on twitter and then we
are jorge vanzero tv on instagram
we got an exciting uh informative
documentary coming
out on a restaurant situation in
southern california
so stay tuned for that and we also have
a mental health story coming out so
yeah stay tuned and uh hopefully we're
not at a civil war next time i see it
or when we do we'll have you back so we
can talk about it yeah i'm coming here
because you have
uh guns good stuff yeah i don't i don't
have nearly
as many as people can i have like if i
were to come what could i get
we don't have enough give me that
amazing over there
what what is that snub nose or what is
that no one can see anything what are
you talking about
nothing there's nothing i meant is it
airsoft
yeah yeah no i like the one that's
behind me
it's fun it's an old 1865 i'm done
yes so the censorship that we're about
to reach
has never been seen before so i was
going to say check out my youtube
channel we are change but
better would be for you to go to we are
change.org and in the top right hand
corner
we you could sign up on our email list
and there's no big tech oligarch
standing in the way between me
and you we are change.org top right hand
corner sign up on our email list it's
free it costs you nothing
and uh definitely check that out shirts
again we are change.org forward slash
shirts if you want to support my efforts
here really appreciate you guys so much
you guys are
freaking incredible i love engaging with
you guys so
sincerely sincerely thank you thank you
thank you right on and of course you can
follow at sauropolis you can't tonight i
was accompanied by my little co-producer
his name is stinky sam
and he's been flying around the room
causing all sorts of trouble are you
guys related
we are related yes how did you know and
and then his friend is um
smelly shelly that's his little wife um
i haven't seen her lately but i love my
co-producers
anyway one of the funniest things ever
is when the cats encounter stink bugs
that's so cool and
my dog tries to eat them oh yeah that's
smart i like that well apparently
people do and they're they're they are
many
anyway thanks for hanging out everybody
uh i hope everybody calms down
and we chill out and things simmer a
little bit but uh
we'll see how it plays out thanks for
hanging out we'll be back tomorrow at 8
p.m live
once again thank you and we will see you
all then bye guys
you